all right and I am live and you are live
so we are live
flash boy Abati's what's going on in
well not much spin kind of a kind of a
busy week haven't been able to play
quite as much as I wanted to so try and
get some grand in this weekend of course
but darlings out there we got some bacon
going on got some different stuff to
talk about this week because table is a
little bit shorter so got a couple
topics to talk about
how's your week been grinding man that
that below 600 grind is real so I've
just been doing everything I can it just
kind of get myself in position before
the new content but shout out the screen
man um what a shower web screen man he's
really good carboxyl really been helping
up helping out all shout to the dude man
he actually started his character on pc
gone from short pause gaming got a
chance to play with him a little bit so
that was fun waiting on a few other
defectors they haven't come yet
so in China you know chatting to the PC
community live and poppin and to the
spawnpoint clan I will definitely be a
little bit more ingratiating once I hit
six hunch I just choose to get myself
right before I throw myself and crazy
activity is Israel the grass real but uh
trust me I tried malfeasance and it was
just like I 580 it was pretty brutal so
any ready it yeah that was definitely
and just the end of that strike
especially kind of small areas heavier
like you know hard hitting enemies and
stuff if you're not quite there it's a
bit dicey like I've kind of ring on my
friends do that around 600 it's like it
hurts oh yeah oh yeah salute to scream
I'll shoot salute the king in the chat
haha yeah man nice looks great he was a
trouper though he was you trying to try
to get me through you know that haha so
it is what it is but uh yeah man don't
worry King I coming through all that
fraud talking to chat I see bro is the
faeces still popping over here we gonna
get you gonna get this if there's no way
to go man because we gonna work on their
defection
ah well get those go what's going on man
we got ha so today we're gonna talk
about the dawning kind of its launch how
it's been
we've got discussions just about the
twelve can a couple upcoming changes
some good kind of some things out in the
community the raid launch just kind of
our thoughts and how just that
progressions been going and then just
finally gonna wrap up with some things
that we are really enjoying about
destiny just cuz its current state and
some things that we really really want
to see change so a little bit of both
but that's kind of a rundown of the
shows he gets kind of having an idea
what's coming but we'll start with the
dawning I mean when you stepped in this
week on Tuesday how's it been going for
you I just messed around a little bit um
effort to be real true like I avoided it
for like two days like I was just like
sound corny I don't know if I'm doing
hey like I just were I was literally
just focusing on engrams in the power
chase but yeah I think it was Chi he was
like you didn't do anything yet and I'm
like nah let me let me mess with it yo
Loki I'll be joining it like it's goofy
but it's funny like first of all I'm a
sample say something real quick I
actually really like this event like I'm
really broke down like yeah yep Easy
Bake Oven literally that's what it is
King let you get the little things and
the names are hilarious and the
agreements are hilarious like oh man run
around vex milk and kapal oil and dollar
doodles and all this other Easy Bake
Oven stuff but it's actually fun it's
rewarding I got the arm
what is it the the machine gun you know
yeah the Avalanche yeah roll is trash
but I didn't care about anything cuz I
got to ship all I want I was gonna
literally spend bright dust to get the
ship cuz I love the way that ship looks
me which one was it
glad tidings on I think it's the glad
times one it looks like a jet fighter
base oh man yeah reminds me of my
childhood i'ma show I'm just revealed my
age now but there's a old cartoon back
in the day called
battle of the planets King know what I'm
talking about he's in it oh geez know
what I'm talking about
and um that was one of my favorite shows
the Japanese anime is called gotcha man
and that was the ship his style was that
kind of jet fighter so I had to get the
blue
shada to match the car to I had to have
that ship so luckily like all my second
recipe or whatever I was able to get it
so I better phone man just doing things
and they be given out in handsome cause
so I'm like alright it gives me
incentive to do it what about you yeah
same thing kind of stepped in the
ingredients have been plentiful when
you're going through we I was grind in a
couple night falls with some buddies and
you're getting like what is it like
thirty any thirty of those like essence
or whatever from word nightfall so I
mean honestly like if you got a good
group and you can speedrun some night
falls that one's pretty efficient if you
can farm some of the loss nonetheless
sectors the public events if you can
find that quick rotation it's like hey
this one's up this one's up this one's
up and you not public about it's pretty
quick on like Eid easy especially as I
get playing it for that because it's a
flashpoint yeah those are pretty good
but I mean yes you said that names are
hilarious you got there Bert edge
transit accident it was over what are
you getting some chance at some drops
the bounties are actually there the
powerful gear is actually a thing to do
so I mean actually give you a reason
it's not just like solely Cosmetics like
if you do so put some time and on this
other grind and you've like you know
done some other things you get some
powerful gear you get a chance to get
some more rolls of the avalanche which I
know some people were going for I got a
decent one it's got tournament right no
it's got feeding frenzy which is non
that big machine guns and I'm trying to
look and see if it's on them right now
and not classified because I got all
week and see if I can actually click on
it and see what I got for a rule we're
gonna be able to get that's gay um well
I got one with dynamic sway reduction
and rampage which is pretty solid ice
nice yeah pretty good and then I got
another one with and then on the other
side I get one with slide ways and hip
fire grip I'm like well those two
couldn't be farther apart for using this
like there's definitely some random
rules going on but it's just nice to see
that this is a drop you can get some
options with it oh I got feeding frenzy
and rampage that was the one I really
wanted so you got ricochet rounds on it
and medium zoom scope in a reload speed
so it's like it's it's a pretty solid
role so I mean just gives me some
options they said they are gonna boot
buff the I'll get to it later they're
just going
of the stability a little bit on that
gun yeah a solo mm-hmm a little bit all
over the place but yeah it's just nice
to have have a specific weapon for for
it it's not crazy overpowered but I mean
machine guns feel broken anyway so I
mean they still hits pretty hard but
yeah like one thing I gotta get man is
like is that sleigh that's the barrel is
just crazy that's like the essence
that's like the essence of Santa like
you are Samson with that Jay like it is
it look it looked pimp like it's like
you got a real you know Lord Shariat the
sleigh needs the reindeer for like I'm
starting a Loki love the dawning like
I've always liked the the aesthetic of
the suits of the dawning I've always
felt like I like last year's dawning on
what you call a suit was really really
cool and I like this year design I like
the color scheme everything about the
design of the event and you know you got
the little stupid snowballs you use that
you know in a field and stuff like that
or like the funny thing is you ever go
to the like the default and did you just
hit oh yeah yeah I was standing there
recording the weekly reset kind of up in
my usual spot like I'm at the ATM really
go hit me but you gotta laugh cuz it's
so funny like I like to go to God it is
low-key my favorite people say like
that's the free of it cuz I'm trying
think we got dawning you got crimson
days you got festival yeah they're gonna
do a new one over the spring
you got solstice absorbers to bring it
back that was new you know what they do
the Solstice was good I did enjoy that
time around so cuz that was kind of a
new thing the missions that they redid
were cool because I really enjoyed kind
of just the work just even the reworked
mechanics on that one with all the
servitor like the russian nesting
servitor at all like that one was
hilarious when those little ones get
just kind of change the feel of it and
then just the reason you had the grind
there was a little extra level to get
more you get that next thing it was it's
been like honestly like the events have
had a nice swing sent like especially
since like you know they made their flub
in the beginning like the first festival
the cost was like they drop
big time wait to have you on that
reverse and stuff like that and now I
gotta say like I like the way the armor
looks you guys can see that stuff on
screen but like Paul Tassie's article
kind of said it really well just with
regards to the armor at this point
really should not be in there like it
should be in random drops should be part
of like all the stuff you're baking just
random bowls because I mean if you're
ever gonna spend money and train get a
full set that you actually want to use
if you don't just want to look pretty
because we don't have trains mock or
anything like that area effects the
random rolls you're never ever ever you
could spend a hundred dollars and still
never get the rolls you want because
your chance to get a piece of armor one
piece much less the rules you want much
less the likes rights lot is like so
like statistically tiny and you would
spend so much money to ever get that
you're not gonna random roll it so it's
like just the armor sitting in there
it's like I'm lucky to even get a set
much less it's like okay if I do get a
full set what are the odds from these
like random engrams that I do get that
I'm gonna get the rolls that actually
want so just the fact the armors sitting
and there's like even more and more
who's saying that's like it just proves
like the armor shouldn't be in there it
looks awesome but I'm never gonna it
like it should be dropping all the time
and maybe it is just low and you have to
infuse it into it like give us more
options for this stuff because like
sticking it just behind the engrams that
you get my plan that's like the one
thing it you know just kind of takes
away because I'm never gonna have a full
set of that that I really hate afraid
you saying are you saying that's a good
point because the armor is cool and you
want other ways to get it as well as
more randomization and I notice with the
festivals armors in general regardless
of it's the dawning or not you noticed a
not rolling with um resilience but it
does each set will have like and
sometimes like all mobility I'm like
that's the last thing I want it's always
like mobility and I'm like fam can I
guess I'm gonna that's why I love when I
abandon comes around cuz those are
always resilience but it's just like you
know a we gonna talk about I'm not gonna
spoil it but we're gonna talk about when
we get it said likes and dislikes we get
to that topic you know some suggestions
there but overall I do like the dawning
it is my favorite event you know out of
the many of it to me it's had the most
consistency besides that one
he was like really expensive right you
know it's my personal yeah I mean it's
been fun I'm not like the way they
handled the like the infinite forest
actually having a full like new activity
was cool and kind of set it above for me
my big one is still mr. Sparrow racing
so whatever that was attached to before
that's my big one on this and said oh
well this is fun bacon and the activity
miss me some sparrows and big time you
get to tight suits out but they was cool
dough it was either skintight speedo
spice videos good you look so good when
you have like a regular orbit top it did
this srl pay it's a city like got big
bulky shutters and then I got like my
underarms or base layer and the hell you
get compression stuff oh it is bad funny
yeah it's really greatly so but yeah I
mean the the donning has been going on
we've been digging in a little bit and
we notice a guy is no evil Levante
return to the oven is out there you can
master work your oven yeah
one piece of advice though make sure you
guys find a way whether looking up
recipes or whatever before you bake all
the recipes and master work it make sure
you bake the burnt edge transit I forget
what they're called yeah you have to do
that one wrong recipe yes otherwise you
can't give the triumph in the event so
and if you mess or work that you won't
be able to do it so keep that in mind
definitely check some recipes out there
there's some pictures that show them all
out there on the internet if you guys
are looking for a link I'll see if I can
find one while we're doing this but make
sure you hit that one because you can't
give a triumph without giving all
thirteen good point which includes the
wrong one so just a piece in mind yeah
mmm agreed Aven comes back she has no
shaders she is not the cosmetics one at
this point which is kind of sad yeah
it's nice nice to see so yeah it's like
this everybody's like the main towers
gone we've shifted over to this other
piece of the wall we're finding the
black armor in there Ava's kind of find
a wandering our way back from the city
into the tower to anything or Kenneth
pieces back here and there so it's good
yep and then but that's like I mean
honestly from this have been see and
stuff like enhancement cores and just
some drops and things like that so I
actually kind of get in some good use
out of this event so far at least in my
opinion yes I agree
I know but yeah it's just the fact I
mean you can get course mods you can get
some gear drops you can get the machine
gun with random roles which is cool it's
nice to see that we get some options but
the baking stuff is kind of cool I mean
you got I forget its chocolate chip
cookies and play of organs and I think
those go to holiday cuz she's of course
the ship you know ship Lainey I forget
what it is but I mean the things that
drop you got like crew uh what is it
cabal oil when you kill those kinda
theme but then you get into like the way
you get personal touches you got to get
melee kills you know like fire you get
the sight like kind of a theme to its a
mix it you're like if you want to if you
want to buy stuff to and if you have a
whole bunch of spare art right duh
sitting around you can pick up a bunch
of that stuff in different ways so they
give you a way to if you're missing
something specific not totally go grant
you're like I have like 500 of this
thing again a lot of essence I just need
to make one more thing yeah you can buy
it so I like how they gave you options
uh buy it if you put in the grind but if
you want to go look for it there's ways
to do it as well so I like how they've
given you options which is good
absolutely give options are always good
and I like the way they've been handling
that whole bow anything and in just the
event in general I agree so and we got
some nice pictures here if you guys are
looking for fun this is a nice picture
the Avalanche 4-fold downing armor have
you used the Avalanche that much I mean
what do you feel about the guy so my
role is trash so I didn't even bother
touching it right now and to be real
chewy ain't nothing moving out since I
got done the Lord to drop as a Rando
mean nothing moving out that's why I
remember you saying that you missed the
question as that random drop was like
damn that's that's lucky
I needed that man cuz like I said
outside of you would get me that whisper
you know I'm saying like to be honest
like I was just like damn I got just you
know I don't have no sleep right around
no power fantasy and then I just forgot
how good and how versatile Thunder Lord
is so it's like I'm just so low in
content you know some of some content by
myself and I'm just like why it's all
because of nun law so it's like from
right now my whole spec is Thunder
Lorelei
machine gun reserves machine gun
scavenger you know I'm saying like
everything is back towards thunderlord
it's just I got to dash out the city
saying is easy cause when you beg for
the gunsmith all I have to do that I'm
not too giddy I'm not to see what's up
with that brought up yeah man but so
I've really got chance to touch I have a
Lynch um shot the cactus he's got a good
video up on it I think he says his vibe
is that um it's not as good as hammer
head but um he's saying like hey if you
don't got hammer it like guys like me
you know you like it but I think the
problem with it right now is like the
kick you got to do something to control
that little to kick a little bit have
you you have you shot ever used it which
one the avalanche should no one yeah
I've used it like they are gonna patch
the stability they said coming up and
we'll talk about that but I mean with
reasonable rolls it still hits pretty
hard because the clip is a little
smaller okay I think it's like 58 or 59
so it's sub 60 so it's a slightly
different clip amount so I think it does
hit pretty hard for what it does man
just the fact that it's solar now you've
got thunder Lord you cover an art you've
got hammerhead with void and you've got
this thing with solar so you do have
some options now for each damage type
which is definitely a good thing we got
in San Pablo we got back up on but fuel
of course making me laugh every time
every job so thank you guys for joining
the TAT center of get you guys out there
of course Lord King and everybody out
there in the aisles chat so thank you
guys for tuning fun fun morning to get
going here but yeah as like Donna has
been fun avalanche is cool the baking's
fun there's some things out there if you
guys are looking on if you can master
work your oven and start baking some of
those cookies definitely look into some
things out there there's some tips you
guys can get a lot of enhancement cores
just by grinding out those little
packages playing activities and then
using those to bake packages those
enhancement cores probably one of those
things that you can get quickest right
now probably for the first time ever
honestly so it's been some time grinding
and that's actually gonna pay off pretty
well with those cores I think that's
gonna be probably one of the biggest
things and then we got to talk about
this pharaoh this thing is crazy town I
love this thing let's go
like seriously like the slave the
holiday spirit is out there you got
glimmer packages coming out of the back
just the fact that you actually grind
for it as well it's not part of ever
versus honestly the nice cherry on top -
you can earn it everybody can earn it if
you put in that time when you got three
weeks to do it it's not gonna be that
hard to get to and just get yourself a
sparrow that's just gonna be nothing is
gonna look like this it's just crazy
city legs roll it up dropping gifts yo
shout-out to the design team we always
give them credit on all flash point but
we got to give them again man well cool
yo e let's be real since D - the
sparrows been lit like that you got the
Ghost Rider looking one they even a John
Deere looking Sparrow like my god
barrels or fire right now like really
good designs like the boring ones are
like yeah they're there but man these
exotics have been really really cool
somebody's been having a lot of fun with
these things
yeah whoever's on that team wood or
Despero team give that man of rays he
needs a little Christmas bonus going on
right now cuz this this is just like I
said this is it's the essence of the
holiday like they just nailed it like
look at that man the imagery is is dope
you know saying then it looks crimped
when you're on it gotta love it
got the gift thing going on and like you
said you can earn it you know about just
the gameplay everyone can get it and
it's not just an instant buy either so
like that's a nice touch yep yeah so I
mean that's it that they're learning yes
backlash too much stuff in at first
they've been making these changes given
us stuff to grind for giving us random
rolls on avalanche we had a horror story
that was very drying for got this
awesome Sparrow that you can go for the
cookies given uh scores now it's like
they're listening they're out there kind
of paying attention making things making
things a little bit better baby steps in
all the right directions and these
little feelings of these events make
them more enjoyable because if you have
this like tarnished feeling or festival
the cost and these like all downtrodden
things and then you come in and now
we're starting to get just positive
feels like hey this is kind of fun this
stuff's got a cool those are the
feelings we need from these events
because it actually keeps it nice and
positive absolutely absolutely but yeah
I mean it's gonna come
a couple bursts per bursts
we got glimmer boost so while boosting
sparrow spawns a little glimmer presence
you can run around and pick those up a
glimmer a trick when a player lands a
trick on the sparrow three or five
glimmer presents are spawned and this is
again only during these three weeks so
the glimmer won't always be there always
got the instant summon which is the
thing everybody wants I think you have I
think every Sparrow should come with
that his works like that that just needs
to happen but I agree yep so yeah
there's gonna be some other tribes and
stuff that you guys can do look through
those but if you spend some time in
there it's the sparrow itself is not
that hard to get you just gotta spend
some time it's three weeks you got
plenty of time absolutely and then of
course we got the double drops the ever
verse emotes are dropping and this is a
good thing too you get your normal once
you get your doubles and like shout out
to you go my ship yeah this one your
little jet fighter reminds me kind of
the shape of the solstice of heroship
but was kind of a slightly different
that's the battle of the planets right
that's two got your mind that's that's
my ship I got the red and blue on that
og force let's go that's much our look
and I love that design love it yeah and
then the snowball goes to school to kept
a little sticks add his arms out there
so it's like I'm a baby snowman over
there on the right and the new thing
these multiplayer emotes are honestly
pretty cool like yeah nice only one
person has to have it like I was
wondering if like both you have to have
it no you can just like hold up a weight
and somebody can come interact with you
so it's nicely yeah you don't have to
own it
yeah not both do cuz like one of my
buddies had it or whatever knees just
hold my hand up there he's like come on
come on you walk up you hit E you press
and hold it does little knows how to
interact so then you high-five them but
you never owned it so it's actually cool
that you can do it with just one of you
having it mm-hmm or as though I did I
didn't know that so you're not cool
because at the end of the day it's not
forcing the microtransaction it's not
forcing you don't say like it's like hey
we're gonna give some to give you to
make you interact with the community so
yeah that's cool I didn't know that I'm
actually gonna stuff cuz I got their
home I get the chest bump one so I don't
get in front of somebody like yourself
fam yeah sound effects when you preview
them or just like they're a little off
and a couple of those but overall it's
cool we've got the hockey throwdown
let's go let's go now on the gun that I
do that before the gambit match before
they get me that's perfect yeah it's
like a little you to hockey the bid like
it what's up no it's like throw down the
stick gloves come off time to fight
let's go that's how we do this sell mmm
and then your exclusive this one you do
have to buy this one is for the silver
is the actual cookies but yes man it's
like you can actually see them pour out
you got the cookie baked and you see
actually melt out and it's a good thing
your guardian because holding that hot
hot cookie sheet would definitely burn
your fingertips but he's a lot the
handle in the fire so yeah but honestly
like if that's the one they put in there
it's like hey this one you gotta buy
it's like yeah there's always gonna be
some things you do have to buy but
honestly they have enough cool stuff in
there that if I miss out on this one I
don't pay for it that's okay like see
and that's the thing people have to
understand it's like no you can't earn
everything they are gonna put some
things in there just like in many other
games give you the option like if you
want it cool if you don't no skin off
your back there's enough other stuff in
there you're not missing out exactly and
it's cosmetic
it does not affect gameplay Norgay
additive advantage it is cosmetic I
don't have no problem with cosmetics in
there under behind microtransaction as
long as they're not ridiculously
overpriced but you know other than that
I'm cool I'm completely cool with this
is no yeah it's like that thousand or
eleven hundred silver so it's like that
ten or eleven buck range something like
that so I mean it's not cheap but it
comes with other stuff too so I mean
you'll get a few extra engrams and
things in there so not bad but you know
they got a throw a little bit out there
there's trying to keep that live team
supported and this is just one of the
ways they support it and again you
always have that choice to support if
you think Daniel passes all you're gonna
put in that is totally your choice if
you don't want to do that one but you're
like hey this emo it's just awesome and
I'm gonna just stick with the normal
content and just have fun grinding up
the level and not play black armory
things you know spend your 10 bucks here
support him that way or not at all
that's again you guys always have the
option remember cosmetics don't mean a
damn thing when you're moving in so you
know appreciate but yeah if you got
brightness piling up you can use that to
buy specific pieces kind of speed your
speed it along so you just have like you
know twenty thousand bright does from
break down breaking down at tons of
ships and shaders and things like that
real quick it real quick again coming to
PC I didn't have any brightness and you
all I was doing is every day
grab those those doughnuts I mean
donning those are test bounties just
grab the test boundaries of just doing
basic things in the game earning bright
does able to get these cosmetic things
so within no time between earning stuff
dismantling stuff that you get on drops
especially ships and stuff that you
don't want you don't be up there and
bright dust in no time so that is a fact
the system definitely it's not trying to
be manipulative yeah
yeah I mean those those are bounding is
that even I don't pick up that often but
I definitely probably should because I
know I have so many notes that I need to
start using just you know stockpile and
that's the hook it's nice if I have you
know I've I've broken it down enough
like homers shaders some of those will
give you some bright dust and little
clumps in if you have like 30 shaders
you're gonna start adding up you know
ships and the sparrows and ghosts and
things are usually gonna give you a
decent chunks I mean I've got like
20,000 bright dust so if I do see that
like that one ship or that one --mode
I'm not waiting on the prismatic matrix
I'm just things like you know what I'll
just buy it don't you know and just try
and save up so it's nice that they are
giving us all those options so yep
darling we'll be going until New Year's
Day it ends because that will actually
be one of the resets so on a calendar
reset will be that day so end up good
old 9 a.m. Pacific on Tuesday January
1st he got until new year right oh uh
yeah so that's pretty much what we got
going for the dawning quick run-through
but good morning
you got me thanks for joining in played
with him a little dishes we couple
grinds drag them some people through
nightfall shadow for the the help out
there this week to talk about for you
guys it's been a good one you know
looking good with the Avalanche and the
armor I'll probably never have that
armor said which is a little annoying
I mean even if I did have the armor set
and probably have like auto rifle loader
like bow bow reserves just like stress I
don't use and I'm just like nope not
gonna use it so that's why can we need
to get into some type of you know we'll
get good good so mmm yep darling is
going on that's the main piece of the 12
they talked about there were a few
hiccups when they when it started I
don't think you were sleeping when all
that went down the first
two hours those servers were struggling
even on PC I was like oh it's like I was
seeing people saying all their troubles
could not console is like I'll battle
Nets got this I get out and I was like
no this is destiny they are they are
struggling you'd be like in the director
and be like call him you load the tower
not even get to the job Wow take him
back to orbit like over here with air so
was like as couple hours and then they
finally said server maintenance was done
by about there's about three total hours
end up being full main snow finally came
back up but during that time it was may
as well not even that was like I
couldn't record my weekly reset video
but it'd be like two minutes in and get
kicked I was like I'm just gonna take a
quick nap came back and it was good
south nice nice yeah it worked out so
after a few hiccups pretty much
everything was rocking and rolling so a
couple things going on for you guys with
black armory things they are working on
changing and just because the first one
is the scourge of the past those who did
beat it in 24 hours they and again if
you're listening to this and you did
congrats and hats off yes I have
definitely not done that but the came
for the first 24 hours is not dropping
and they done it so just they've got to
fix it and it will be rubble
sent out to people who did are in it
when they fix it so it's just an issue
but they'll know they have the data and
who did it and yeah long as they
acknowledge it that's what's up but yeah
this time I heard it was we can honestly
probably just jump into the right
discussion now let's do it so I heard
there was about 900 ish teams that
probably beat it in the first 24 hours I
think between whatever first 50 teams I
saw somebody post a stat that it was
like 46 on PC maybe 3 on ps4 1 on Xbox
one or vice versa but I mean very very
very PC heavy for those hardly a peep
that I did peep that yeah huge disparity
there and it kind of it kind of mimics
what happened with our last wish right
cuz last wish was PC first so yeah
definitely the hardcore community is
here oh no I mean listen at the other
day you know you know that is
interesting to see you know I'm saying
though how those numbers skew
I'm a little concerned about my console
bredrin you know just like what's going
on there
you know um or is it just point of entry
kind of things
that's very curious to me that it's so
ski especially with ps4 being the you
know what the exclusives on a platform
should be a little higher so it is
interesting it is interesting that the
you know a lot of people are not getting
that you know getting the raids done
around that time so I'm curious to see
if they think about something as far as
addressing nap for future content I'm
very curious to see how they feel about
that yeah I mean so that's just like the
type of people who are gonna play that
it's like it was only on console before
but some of your more like crazy
hardcore people I'm not saying there's
not hardcore hardcore people but they
want that best experience and that does
I mean you know just like one clear no
it wasn't only that I was just going
through first 50 like there may have
been like 900 in the first 24 hours but
the first 50 like the first initial
batch was like probably heavier PC
weighted than more people were finishing
it throughout the day but the first 50
was very very heavy pcs so okay there
may have been more like I mean remember
when cactus he was one of the first one
who's one at first he was the first ISIL
for last wish he was the first on
console to do it and there were probably
more that came but it was just that
initial push the first ones was those
like some of the more hardcore people
seem to be on that on the new PC
platform which is just interesting to
think about so okay this you pumping
your chest out are you what this is this
you masterrace it right now focus this
coming from the guy who's not going back
to console this cover from the guy who
dragged me to please see but yeah for
the raid itself the raid recommended
level was gonna be it's 640 now we had
three days to get here the average
person versus the people who actually
were in that you know kind of raid race
which actually was a fairly competitive
one I mean it was done in what was it
two hours two to three I think a lot of
people were starting to finish up a good
chunk of it was in there what do you
feel about recommended level the people
who actually did the race the levels
they were gone in in just kind of this
whole initial like leveling grind
and how this whole release is gone how
do you feel so far like how it's been
for some how it is for others and you
know what I'm talking about I'm trying
not to say yeah yeah you know this is
gonna be a regurgitation of last
flashpoint you know I just think it's
wack like I just think it's like you
know at the end of the day you know guys
are going in there you know listen I'm
not mad anybody who knows what to do
with the system hey if you know what to
do with the system and you hold on or in
grant and stuff like that and that
proves to work for you by all means you
know I'm saying do what you got to do
I'm not knocking the hustle all I'm
saying is like you know the rest the
rest of the population is struggling out
there to get into this content so again
it's leveling it's all morning you know
stuff that we've kind of talked about
before and on with the raid you know if
if they're gonna figure out a way to
stifle which most like they're gonna do
next time which is stifle those guys for
doing those exploits to get to starting
new content then it's like okay why are
you so punchy why are you so quick to
put the raid out that Friday you know
when you figure 80% what should we say
about like 80% am I being generous
saying 80% we're not love 95% of people
weren't heard are you kidding exactly so
and that was me being generous right so
you figure that but at the end of the
day it's like what about just moving it
back that week like you did last wish
give people time to grind you know the
rest can really so more people can enjoy
the content cuz I think what's happening
right now is that you know you've got
great content there but if people are
frustrated that they can't get to that
level I don't say frustrated but they
know that they have so much more work to
do then and then everybody else do you
see the top 5% or 1% getting it done you
know sometimes that discourages people
from you know wanting to to do the
content and again I'm not trying to say
make things easier and all super
casualization cuz we know where that
leads not going in all I'm saying is
they I think they still have to figure
out the leveling that's it's still off
it's still not where it needs to be so
as far as the rate
salut tous dudes that got it done I did
get a chance to check it out it looked
cool I have one comment I was probably
gonna lead into one of my likes and
dislikes I might spoil it one the great
itself is cool I like the encounters I
like the sparrow I like you know being
in the city the city scale looks dope I
like that I don't like is okay they told
us then we're gonna go away from
cinematics fine how come I can't have
lore how come I can't have voice
narrative similar to how when we you
know you beat force Aikens main campaign
you open the Dreaming city Petra starts
talking to you right this is what we got
to do not ever Riven this is what we got
to do I don't know why are we here why
are we in the city what's going on
there's a little blip afterwards that we
got from 801 but that was like post
beating and talking about the pages and
stuff like that so we got a little bit
well wasn't gonna tell me cuz I didn't
see that so basically like once the raid
was finished they did kick off like a
change in the world so when you go talk
to Ava she mentions the fact that the
book which is what you're going into in
there it's like the book or something
from the black armory was stolen by the
Fallen and cannot remember the guys name
civics are what second civics or
something like this no no well done no
but like civics was like the one who
stole it but then she says it's like hey
the pages were ripped out from the book
so there's still some stuff we've got to
go do and that's where this continual
kind of release of some of these forges
are gonna be but it's also some people
are saying it's like this say it sounds
like the lore of the rate itself is
supposed to be something that comes like
once you've beat all the forges so like
the orderings a little bit off but there
is a little bit of a flight continuation
of story there and what I just think
some of its like kind of at a place and
then if you're just one of those like
clicks through let me get my bounties
and does it pay attention to it right
you miss the whole little bit right but
here's a day I don't think but little
baby like doesn't have to be full
rendered cinematic just kind of the like
the I want to say like sketch feel to
him like when they did those little bits
like
like that's like when you talk to her
for the next time after that everybody
gets that little Sanna be like hey first
scene went in there we talk to this and
we get that feel and it just explains a
little more it doesn't have to be this
way full Windham surrendered cinematic
but yeah a little bit would be nice put
it this way even if they actually
regressed from Leviathan in my opinion
as far as narrative law even Calais was
talking you know yes come in here you
know I'm saying whatever whatever you
know and then that should be you know
grow fat from strength and you know all
this up at least it was something like
this guy you know aka the metal gear
right at the end nothing like this
there's no talk there's nothing you know
the ghost doesn't say anything like that
was just like damn like why are we here
what did what was their goal I mean that
we got Conor what their goal is but
again like you said reading bounties and
stuff like that but I'm watching these
dreams and I'm just like this all looks
cool just give me some narrative reason
while we're here and some voice
narrative as to you know while we're
doing it that's my main you know I know
I made probably going extra hard on them
but I have to because they've set the
precedent forsaken even Leviathan had
that like Leviathan you flew in okay
cool you know II didn't say much there
but at least when you landed Calais is
talking to you right you know welcome in
each section of the thing you know
you're going through they had that with
forsaken beautifully you know I'm saying
beautifully as soon as you walk in even
even after you beat the techeuns right
they you know she's talking hey I was oh
I was out of could you know under
control go get my sister ribbons to it
it was beautifully done what what
happened we can't we can't do that now
it expensive it's as like and that's the
that's the balance they're looking for
they're trying to like see what the
piece is like what do we what are the
people want how far do they go how far
do they take like do they like the story
missions the cinematics the voiceovers
this is all that bounce they're trying
to figure out right now and there's just
gonna be like a work in progress so I
mean I'm with you to the point where
a little bit more would be good because
it's always this kind of question mark
of like a little bit what's going on and
so it's like we know we're going in
there we know we've got the black
armories this new thing open and it's
like innate is like okay so it's like I
can't do much because I can't get back
to the forges so you go you fire up your
first Ford you come back and she's like
you know got this little torn mentality
of like she's not a big fan of guardians
but you're helping her out so she's
trying to like you know you are the you
you're what's making it work so I got to
work with you ii forward stuff like that
and then the raid discussion about the
book and the page is just like little
bits more and there was like the graphic
when you talk to spider the first time
he's talking about all the barons
talking about each one that little
animation that one's really really cool
and that would be just something like
does OB be full-blown but even a small
pulled back version of that talking
about here's the book you know it was
our founders book and had these things
in there it's like in this demographic
of cynics like ripping the pages and
running it doesn't have to and it can be
like storyboard it doesn't have to be
animated like that you know kind of
moving storyboards and you have see the
at least kind of idea what's going on
doesn't always have to be those those
small touches add a lot to give you that
little board more feel and motivations
to go after that stuff you nailed it
with the baron's cuz that wasn't a full
cinematic I remember when I again
getting on PC having a replayed it for a
second coming I forgot about that when
you talk to spider and he's telling you
about the baron's and they're showing
you the little storyboard you know art
sketch kind of stuff that's all they
really need it that's literally it
you don't have to go full-bore with you
know howdy 2's first you know launch
with their cinematics you can just do
that and be fine but they cannot go away
I'm not gonna let them off the hook of
going away and regressing on things that
they've already done and I know in
people goes oh it's an annual pass it
doesn't matter you set the expectation
you've just had a great content wrap all
I'm saying is continue that narrative
that's all yep so yeah there's some
issues of real live tokens people like
not actually running out of Reebok toge
in tokens and some glitch with that so I
know there was like maybe a asterisks on
some raid first and stuff but it was
overall I mean the people who were going
for it I mean you know watching dad oh
he got like 20th because people were
it was it was a pretty tight race there
was a lot of people involved shout out
to gigs they didn't win it all so I mean
they're gonna be getting there a lot of
those teams about jackets again yeah
that's something that like it crazy to
get don't know if I'll ever get to one
of those but maybe some point dollar it
would be cool yeah we just got to save
our high-end banner of bounties forever
and then we'll be rich like no kind of
getting more into that discussion layers
yeah put a pin in that for a second we
will get back to those in a little bit
but for the black armory forges you guys
if you are playing I'm a couple things
to make note of some weapon frames may
be lost from inventories like on weekly
reset the high-value to the postmaster
was actually not getting some things
like I noticed the modulus reports were
not going and they mention it so I
didn't have to say it but like I didn't
have enough spacing consumables and I
did a couple of those like the daily
bounties Wow certain things that weren't
going to the postmaster and moving
enough outs some things weren't quite
right so basically if you're doing black
armory stuff for one you get these the
ballistic log so those are what lets you
get the full weapon frames which are
kind of your powerful things for the
week make sure you you know get your
ballistics log get your weapon frame
finish that in the week because those
ballistic logs go away now this is on
Bungie because they did not make that
clear everybody like hey I got the
ballistics logs I'm not gonna be able to
get the weapon frame I'll save it for
next week and lock and get it and then
we're gone well that's one of those
pieces where it's like unclear there
should be this thing on the actual item
itself saying hey this will disappear at
reset or there's a timer on it something
like that saying this stuff's gone do it
before then and they did not make it
obvious that's another piece where it's
a lack of you it's a failed
communication and that's one of those
things that is important so ballistics
logs they go away at weekly reset mmmm'
make sure you have space and your
consumables in your pursuits when you
guys are doing this stuff so you have
space to do what you need any of the
stuff that you pick up and you have
places for it to go because if you don't
you might be losing it while they're
working on fixing it so make sure you
got space do the stuff within a week and
just you know follow through and only do
one at a time that's the other piece
don't have multiple in your inventory
because if one clicks off and the other
doesn't it doesn't quite count right so
design within the reset and have space
I'll just say that multiple times
because I don't wanna have a so that's
just all I've heard it a lot out there
and people are just kind of upset so
just a warning especially if you're
getting into it you know make sure and
listen to those three pieces so yeah I
agree but a preview for next week's
patch no no this is where we're gonna
get in get into stuff people are level
up some newer players you switching over
to PC these are all things that are
gonna help now last week they said
they're gonna increase the power jump
when you get prime engrams and are gonna
be coming more frequently you're like
cool then we're gonna work on getting
that patch going and that one's going
right now that one is actually in effect
with the priming grams have you been
playing enough this week to like notice
your steal a few more I've been I've
been playing a lot of primary engrams
I've been dropping more frequently um
you don't like has the level bump been
it's okay it's okay I'm not gonna say
it's you know it's trash I would say
yeah it's sometimes like you get it you
get a ten-piece jump you know so I will
say it's big like that's more than I
ever see so that's noticeable it
fluctuates at first rate you get a 10
sometimes you know five or six whatever
um yeah I mean they got to do more of it
and that's what I'm looking for for two
point one point three because um you
know I'll just get into a mini thing
right here it's just that yeah for you
don't say right there yeah yeah because
are the other days like this you know
and first of all you know I am NOT about
the casualization of this game I'm not
trying to tell people to shift in one
tell Bungie to shift in another
direction and make everything accessible
for everyone all I'm saying is when you
drop new content right and the way black
armory is set up you know that's endgame
content so you 600 and those that you
guys are struggling from 6 to 650 right
now you have a huge section of the base
that now let's say it's like hey I'm
gonna get into it you know we at this
point could not recommend black armory
to a new player because you literally
would not be able to you know I'm saying
like even access to content so what they
have to do which is what I liken what
I'm seeing with two point one point 3 is
say hey we've got to get those guys that
are forsaken and pre forsaken
up to level in a faster way so this way
you know those guys don't get frustrated
for the two to three week grind and me
and you have had conversations about
this e off you know or flashpoint and
that's the thing you know saying because
now I'm experiencing it as a new
Guardian on PC I'm like man like this is
I'm playing a lot ye like I'm putting in
the work you know I'm saying like I'm
going hard I'm doing all my bounties I'm
doing all my powerful engrams
you know I'm saying I'm trying to get
stuff done and it's been a slow creep
and it kind of sucks like I want to
catch up get to where you were it looks
like at least try the forage like I
can't even try you know say kind of
things so seeing them do these kind of
things I want to see it obviously I want
to see how much of a significant drop
these are high power rewards give so um
yeah let's see man let's see but that
that's pretty much where I'm at with it
where were you at with it when you hear
about you know these the under six
hundred power crew I mean watch and use
a perfect example because this is the
idea like when you get a new expansion
you have new content that people want to
play they work on addressing the forge
they do want it to be in-game content so
you're kind of have a balance of you
don't have this like Story 2 level you
up a bit and kind of be easy win and
then there's pieces where we can get to
that not kind of save a little bit but
it's like these are the steps that need
to change because as you said the
content that people want to get to is
the new stuff and getting people like
having a chance to get towards that like
let me hit the old cap it's the old cap
not the new one let's get to that old
cap quick then you can work on slowing
it down and kind of like face them down
and be like hey when you get up to 595
being slowed down a little bit 600 a
little bit more 605 you'll feel that
gradual progressions where okay now the
ground is getting real but up to there
like 5 to 600 look I'm kind of stepping
on one of my points already but that
soft cap has got to move past the moles
God to man it's got to it's got to
you've got to encourage people to play
your new content and and they've always
historically struggled with old content
whenever a new content drop have yep you
know that's just been a Bungie thing
like making old rays irrelevant you know
I'm saying like they've
they've got great old content just make
it relevant and give people incentive yo
if you do the old content and you'll get
you still get high bumps that you get
right into the field eventually you know
what it would what a concerted effort
and um you know again this is a step in
the right let's give them credit this is
a step in the right direction you know
I'm saying I think black armory is a
learning experience with this new
in-game experiment so to speak so um you
know we'll see you see how it goes on
from like the drifter and penumbra so um
you know I mean that's pretty much what
I got to say on it because like I said
as a hardcore player hellbug in a chat
with so it's a deleted it tried to make
it slow-mo a lot of people to chat it's
good to see so um yeah it's like you
know at the end of the day like for a
new player coming over I'm experiencing
what it's like so you know just to have
that them cater to say hey let's get
these engrams going let's get these guys
up to 600 so they're nice then they can
then be throttled and start the new ride
I have no problem with being throttled
at the 600-mile let's just get us up
speed yep so yeah it's like been there's
a little tweaks and stuff and there as
you said they're getting there they're
working they're not there yet but it's
like they're they're starting to see
what kind of needs to happen so other
issues are going they're working on
getting a sparrow for getting all the
eggs they're getting what is it so just
random little fixes up a thousand voices
is getting a change on PC it was doing
more damage at higher frame rates so
they're bringing it down unfortunately
not bringing the others up though that's
like 144 frames are frame people stuff
like that like when you're running that
fast it was doing more damage and I
think people are really enjoying that or
maybe taking advantage of it I don't
know how extreme it was but now that
thousand voices coming back down I'll
kind of wonder where it's it's after
this because I mean I've seen people and
again playing on PC it's like I'll have
people like you know spray the ground
around the corner from me and I still
die and I'm like that thing is insane
and so I don't know they're getting
those benefits or it is still just that
insane for a normal person so we'll just
have to see where it stands after like
yeah but I've always felt when I got hit
by that thing it just it felt unnatural
life like it's these as near you and
you're dead
I agree yeah so I mean that one's
getting a tweak we'll see where it falls
a couple things about shaders and things
like that most of that stuff is going to
be and they don't put a date but that
supposed to be next week right
like 18th is the cheap 1.3 yeah so let
me next week so I mean the big thing
about the grind coming up but we'll talk
more about that also next week for one
have you jumped into mayhem yet please
tell me meth
oh I have not yet I have my god Billy
that's my baby - I'm most literally part
of the your job sir before the podcast
requirements of course of course you
know I love mayhem without having played
it I'm actually kind of curious this
works for a blind discussion yes what do
you think is gonna be a popular thing to
use now that we have all our options and
I can probably tell I'll tell you but I
want you to guess the easy guess would
be my Nova warp or how beastie it is but
I think right now it is a little watch
my language oh the cleanser keep it
clean keep it clean but there's a little
you know jerk metal going alright now we
do run around with the ohm hunters are
running around with tractor cannons and
tethers acting up I heard so that's what
I heard
but I didn't that's not in me as that as
that was going on
nope not at all let me see give me one
more guest if you won't get home all
right
any of warlocks are not even in the
discussion I don't think let's just say
you don't have to aim the damn thing
always blade barrage gotta pee
everywhere here you don't have to think
you don't aim you jump up you get two
throws on groups of enemies and it's
just and some of them I swear I know may
him as fast I swear they almost get that
crap instant I don't know if it's broken
I literally need to jump on my hunter
and see how it feels now I don't know if
it's certain exotics they're helping to
come back but I swear one dude throws it
at me and then I swear in like the death
screen he's turning around and doing it
again now I could be crazy because there
could just be multiple people throwing
it but I was like I literally wanted
horn and see Lake it is everywhere
and it'll honestly the one I figured cuz
if you see that thing in crucible you
see it in you can't dodge that thing
it's too fast you can't
ultimate no nullify it's faster because
it even wouldn't know the bum you got
like a split second to react and try to
get out of it right if you jump right on
whatever if you blink or whatever this
time I've timed it I've tried blinking
when you when a hunter does that you're
not getting away and then isn't it if
they got shards of gallon or that it's
back on again what's that excited it's
not example sis I don't know what the
shards one does cuz I don't hey yeah
sharks a gallon or there's dramatic in
there that may be what's given them that
recharge time crap mmm-hmm and see
mayhem was one of those things were it's
like the tweaking of super versus super
and this is one thing you don't run into
as often when you're doing normal
crucible and you know it's like plays
and stuff like that there you go shards
of gallon or one and a half seconds
return of super Chad it's like okay so
I'm not crazy so he does it to me and if
he hates me it's that like burn over
time I guess they're that quick recharge
and like it takes me a little bit to get
my super back and mayhem like you hang
around but I mean it's like 20 seconds
is still pretty quick but I got a run
around I have time to shoot some stuff I
can watch the bar go up hang around and
get it back but she threw it and then
it's like man it was like a few seconds
later done I'm like what the hell just
need to hit a target not even kill it
yeah thank you dramatic forgive me that
I just haven't played my owner so yeah
that is insane
so that's why you're new no yeah I box
who said shots a gallon or giving back
super depending on how many killed okay
so what it's doing is it's functioning
like a warlock skull of amon korra which
is yes like yeah alright so the more the
more you kill the more you get bat o
guardians are always powerful enemies so
I mean that's a naught is the got some
some old pete meta sinister unes oh I
don't want to hear nothing about
hundreds a week this is the forsaken
meta is for the hunters baby yeah y'all
out here that that blades down to I want
stuff blades is a product cannot get
away from that you know I'm saying
shards is but it's good to see hunters
needed that man you know Titans was
running things for a while warlocks have
been in there so III don't necessarily
mind it but I see what you took if I got
it I'm saying that while I have no
experience playing man so when I play me
I'm I'm cursin hunters out oh yeah like
jump in there we'll talk next week cuz
we got nice things we have two weeks of
mayhem so I'm hoping to get it back in
the rotation they said they did but we
haven't for two weeks straight and it's
basically one of those things to where
we do have some options with it but I
want you to play it so you can actually
give me some experience for me what I'm
feeling but the other thing I wanted to
talk about is the super versu per we go
will distract it like let's go there are
times I'm literally walking around in
hammers I have a traveling super I'm
literally throwing the hammer it's in
the air and like they have that
wonderful like a little bit of lag
timing we're like okay and they're you
know say it's play brush and they can
top that they take my sumer they do
enough damage to kill me but they took
hammer in the face and they didn't die
and that is the balance of like okay so
I literally threw it midair before you
got it off and then just like extra
shield time while you cast your super
even if it should I can't kill you and I
lose interesting I mean and there's a
personally an issue with like certain
supers are more powerful than others and
I'm like if I hit you first you should
still die because I'm in vice like so so
like there's some of those balances of
certain thing I was like you know trying
to do I'm not the talented one with Nova
warp just because I've never hardly used
it but yeah there's certain ones where
it's like it's doesn't feel fair to all
supers because there's ones that
overpower some are quicker than others
some do that quicker burst some have
that roaming section but if I my hammers
in the air you shouldn't win I'm sorry
but that's just [ __ ] if you get off
first that should be the prevailing
super I mean that's that's just how it
should be so I'm an agreement I'm gonna
agree with you and I do see that some
supers tend to have that you know that
armor on them so to speak right that um
you know yeah
it seems a little low unfair you know
saying so yeah I agree with you
you joined they got they have to look at
that especially with balance and like I
said we already know Nova warp is coming
with a nerf so you know will they touch
shards I'm insurance will they touch
bleh barrage you know we'll see you know
but um it's definitely dominant there's
no doubt about it yeah so I mean that's
been a thing if you guys have any
thoughts you know throw them and chat of
course right now thank you guys for the
influence of boogie Greece yes it's just
that feeling because I mean even with
your shields and stuff like that it's
like I'll whale on people with multiple
supers and they have one quick kill and
I'm like alright I'm screwed so I mean
you can walk around with a shield and
you know take some damage and stuff like
but it's there's certain times where I'm
just either throwing hammers or Smashing
around but it's like they just get that
one quick instant and now Thunder crash
may have that option because you're
gonna travel through the air but then
it's like I want to see like a thud and
this is where like I need to probably
get some people in there it's like I
want a thunder crash up on mayhem in
private matches and have somebody like
as I'm flying through the air dude blade
brush and I want to see who wins that
because that's kind of like that'd be an
interesting thing the test because you
have the flight time but you are and
you're super still and you are supposed
to have that one big hit and if you
can't even land that thing before you
get killed with blades then that's like
that's one of those like you can't like
make it you can't you have to land and
if you can't you're screwed so yeah
there's probably some testing that
people need to do and I'm curious but
that whole superber super you see it a
lot more now and it just makes those
times when I'm like dammit I had my
super on and I still lost the other guy
but I was like I swear hit him first and
now I'm just seeing it more no it's just
yeah you got to get in there let me know
your thoughts that don't just live in
your noble work makes up your supers let
me see how it goes like see how they all
feel and play against others I was just
like for testing I kinda wanna for
multiples and then we'll see how next
week I gotta get my third so classer
that's that's been the issue right now
yes we've been trying to help me and
we're just so which one did you get did
you not like the level like the random
drop from the the blend well yeah so
basically what happened is you know
first choice when I was launched when I
first got the game with you you had me
go chaos reach I'm glad I did that
that's my TV
for the most part you know I'm saying
I'm doing that all the time then I'm
like ad don't like it for Chris well as
much even with this you know the thing
you know normal up is just King so I
needed to get know well so I couldn't
play crucible more so that did that
second but then I've been kind of just
in blind well and it looks like it's not
dropping like I've been grinding round
well thinking that
tier 3 would give me it again and it's
not so I think it's tied still
specifically to UM cheer to to yet well
I think the third seed of light is tied
to the Cali raid part encounter and the
the Mara saw of ascending thing yeah so
I can tell you how I got money because I
finished my you next week it's humming
one is from our Sauve so that's where
you get your week one but one is in
there's one you get in blind well
guaranteed yeah it was packed so that's
why I got I got one into yeah mmm did
you get on a tier 2 or um I think I got
it on I'm pretty sure I got it on a
heroic okay like I think that's almost
like a guarantee so then I third just
spend some time I'm blind well next week
hit that hundred percent on that weekly
and then go talk to her and you'll have
it next week yeah which one that man cuz
yeah I gotta get back there cuz right
now I really need that for you know pre
um black armory you know I'm saying like
what I need my little radiance always
felt that helped me when I was under
level trying to do high-end content so
that is a must not like I miss my well
radius or misma a missing let's go it's
yeah it's definitely a thing I got the
Phoenix Protocol that thing in well of
radiance is a big win for PvE because if
you get a decent amount of kills in your
will of radiance you do it on a strike
or clearing like ol bunch or a Tad's
yeah like I get done and I'm like over
half ready to go again I'm just like
sweet like in a pretty good spot and
that's like some of these exotics like
really help in specific supers like
those are the things where some exotics
they'll feel like they have a purpose
and other ones like knucklehead radar
get out of here seriously
yep
but yeah iron banner is coming the last
week of the dawning so it'll be our
first iron banner of season 5 got a
little uh new new look on the armor here
nice little color scheme we got rotating
right now so that is gonna be December
25th so starts on Christmas Day if you
guys are gonna have some time away to do
that and ends on New Year's so as always
and Christmas and New Year's a year
apart what do you think in the new look
of course I mean iron banner always has
its feel but I'm diggin the color scheme
yeah feelin it I mean this iron man Dave
um I mean the last couple iron bands
they've gone with the Oriental being you
know this is cool you know I like I like
the design I can't can't war life
looking snazzy hunter look cool you feel
about that uh that hunter arm hood
though I'm curious it's got like a
little uh got like a little crown but
like how its I mean head looks a little
more ornate but I like the way it's kind
of the flowing case I'd say that like
the Titan looks smaller like the head is
a little more like just shapely inform
the shoulder pads aren't that big like
and it's like I don't know if you use in
a female or male model but it definitely
looks like a thinner Titan model for a
shirt so and even the mark almost blends
into the armor so I mean yeah it's like
yeah I would definitely say the hunters
cloak kind of sets it apart in the robe
looks pretty good on the Warlock in the
hell Mia x with Loki this time I'll be
yeah yeah the same time there's like the
Loki one you know cuz even the sash is
kind of just small like yeah it's a
little green thing but it's basically
gray blending in with the pants like
it's barely they're like both the
Warlock and then even the pants on the
hunter have that like offset color in
like it's just like it's great from the
waist down and no even gold on the shins
so it's like this chills so somebody was
like somebody worked on the first two
models be like crap only got an hour let
me do this real quick like
there's always fun you guys get a ton of
you know if you grind out your dawning
you've got your cooking all done you're
like at a kind of level if you want a
way to get some powerful gearing like
you trying to get your level up and
stuff you know seven powerful gear
bounties that's huge spending some time
in crucible so you'll get your dailies
you'll probably do that twice in the
week you'll get your weekly four five
matches
you got your bounties to work on I mean
that's that's a lot of powerful gear
just from doing PvP and if you don't
want to that's one of those things where
I wish like the bounties would have kind
of a graduation of difficulty too so if
you want to do like you know if you want
to do so you're like you're five daily
matches you might knock out like one or
two and then they kind of progressed to
get harder and then maybe like you know
the top two or like powerful gear plus
almost like the really long grinds will
give you an even bigger boost is in the
time but those who don't have time to
spend like 30 matches in iron banner in
a week which I know that shortened the
time on some of those would be able to
get some done so like it'd be kind of
cool to see that progression in some of
those bounties to be like hey these top
two are gonna be like you know a little
bit extra special and they're gonna be
like black armory boosts or priming gram
boost and the others are gonna be your
smaller ones because if you have a seven
and they'll give you like one or two
light level just like daily crucible
match or something
those don't feel like they have the same
effect when you have to spend that much
time on crucible yeah a little bit of
right in those I think might be nice I
know it's kind of a random thing to say
but just on the moment thought but we
got a couple year one guns coming back a
new emblem new shader we got the soros
looks like the SMG and then the hand
cannon and I forget it's like per Meli's
dagger or something like that
but they're kind of pretty oh yeah
they're coming back with random roles so
that is saying I'm looking forward to
that because um I'm a huge fan of the
Duke and I believe it's a 110 criminals
dagger and now with random roles and
because it had good beasts that so I'm
very excited to get their hero's burden
was my baby but just smg's are just not
in a good place
ever since shotguns came back so I mean
I'm an idiot but I'm really looking
forward to that a criminal's that i
think that may have some potential yeah
just for that kind of quick
he taps I mean it's like if you got
stuff like Lunas are not forgotten Lee I
mean yeah those are a heavy grind but if
you can't get them I mean they make
every other hand cam yeah look not
worthwhile in PvP packs no but it's nice
to see and this is one thing like we'll
get to it too but it's like you're one
scum and coming back we'll put a pin in
that because that's kind of an important
piece that's gonna be for our likes and
dislikes and stuff like that but uh
bounties they said will function the
same way powerful engrams and they
unlock the piece of armor underneath it
so if you want the full set do all the
bounties for that character and you can
actually buy them all with just the
tokens you get so so it'll be good and
nice thing it'll be a double Valor in
triple valor weaken as well
so Christmas right there you'll have the
double Valor and then over that weekend
again that triple dollar so if you're
looking for again starting to get some
work on those quests if you didn't
interest and you had to start over like
those nieces that's your time because
right now you're just doing some basic
and I swear I'm getting like less of
valor and mayhem not a loss that I'll
move like six and I'm like this is
really I want I need to go do like a
quick play and like I need to compare
those cuz I man I was playing and even
just like on a little street goes like
it barely budged and I'm on like what's
the first look like the second tier like
brave or something like brave two or
three it's creeping slow I'm only at
like $300 it's going like snail's pace
right now so I gotta see if those are
different for quick play or from mayhem
they tone it down because those matches
are a little faster but um I mean that's
kind of one of those like if you put
time in like don't don't change them so
I'm gonna have to see if I'm just crazy
but man it feels slow right now so
definitely a grind so yeah there were
definitely some patch issues stuff like
that again December on 18th will be two
point one point three with the boost of
the 600 gear and things like that
Ava's back so think about the dawning
anything involved at the dawning whether
it's triumphs whether its bounties
whether it's weekly bounties anything
like that has to be claimed and
completely done before it ends because
come January first reset everything is
gone so don't hang on to anything
leave pursuits in there you have to
finish them or you won't get a chance to
finish them so make sure you do that
please don't leave anything out there
let's see and then a couple videos of
course three man flawless scourge of the
past's these guys are just crazy mmm
that's nuts
seventh column with the chaperone sounds
insanely impressive I haven't seen that
one so so weak are definitely some
highlights for sure and then some high
five in action though uh but yeah
there's always some cool art out the
community I do like how buns you will
just like have it out there in the
community and just pull stuff for my
other Twitter posts or other community
people and they just throw some of them
up there because the artists out in the
Destiny world I mean some people like
they draw they want you'll see stuff
over different games but destiny brings
some of the coolest art to the game
itself by people who just love the game
and they're just artists they're like
hey I love the game I'm gonna do a
drawing you get stuff like this from the
community it looks awesome
so yeah these things are really really
cool so that art school there will be
one more table next week yeah that will
be the last one of the year so that'll
probably be your last podcast of the
year will be next week so take a little
break with Christmas traveling and
holidays and things like that and then
probably when they come back we will as
well unless there's something crazy that
happens but also next week will be the
last forge the launches will have a
little time to talk about that kind of
see and then they even take a break on
the calendar of activities till like
January 8th so we're gonna have some
downtime well give you guys a couple
weeks off we'll still be playing of
course but you not have to listen to our
rambling because they get a break for lo
foot yeah so I'll just kind of leave a
graphic up for now but I know we got a
couple other topics to talk about so
we've kind of touched on the raid the
new character grinding but I mean do you
want to hit those any specific like
touches that we haven't gotten to yet on
those first is there anything else you
want to cover about the raid kind of the
way that was leveling the way people are
saving stuff is there anything you think
we didn't touch there already
um I mean for the most part like I said
just what really wanted to talk about
the design of it and the you know the
ball stuff and I've already voiced my
displeasure with the narrative stuff
but as far as the rate itself it looked
fun you know I love that section with
the sparrows and having to go you know
race through that wild craziness with
that what is it that server to chasing
you yeah it almost looks like it reminds
me of the flaming servitor from either
prison or the nothing strike it has that
look but it looks bigger so yeah and I
like daunting to be chasing you
yes and I like the mechanic of them once
you get through that part
both Guardians have to get to the door
like close it at the states I think
that's a good feel you know on that one
can people actually carry like if to
make it and closed in the other ones I
will they eventually be able to get the
checkpoint no respawn them there's a
checkpoint and it we spawn the rest of
the group so it was yes Ferro race with
randoms like not everybody's great at
that so carrying some people through
there you might be like alright I'm
driving we doing this don't bump into me
we're gonna carry you guys if you make
it make it you don't you know yeah we'll
get to the end so like that's gonna be
one of those things and that's kind of a
nice thing too is they need some pieces
and raids where we have those like hey
I'm gonna clutch it moments because
everything's been like everybody has to
do everything's no mudgin like last wish
has been nobody can drop a ball because
otherwise the whole team is screwed like
you can't flush for someone yeah we're
help someone and now this is nice nice
to see that you can I agree so yeah and
then obviously the boss I was looking at
the mechanics at though the boss is
interesting you know saying like what
you fight that's yeah it's very
interesting what you find out - a little
MechWarrior action there if you remember
that from an older game but yeah those
big Olmecs walking around sweet-looking
I kind of like how it's like it's a
substantial thing I think they get the
tanks involved that you can like it's
some nice fun mechanics they can do with
more of an outdoors space and like you
know kind of down to earth in the city
and mechanical stuff how do you feel
about that map mechanic like what
everything seems to be revolved around
looking at a map and one person giving
out instructions and how I felt about
that part I mean I thought it was kind
of cool you have to like keep that
platform open so you gotta clear the
servitor quick so some persons managing
that it's kind of have the point where
you have teams going out kill stuff and
tell them where to go so it's
I mean it's it's like an interesting way
to manage because we normally don't have
like a big open space for a mechanic
it's just like here's a room for an
encounter or here's this thing you have
to progress through it's like here's
like almost an open world area and you
have to be able to navigate around it so
it's a different spin explaining the
directions to newbies might be a little
harder but if you like split into trip
like you know pairs then you just stay
with this person then people know what
they're doing can carry so I like how
they took a you know something where you
have like a puzzle to do but you
actually have somebody like one person
managing kind of coordinating a team
type thing so it's a cool feel like it's
I mean I'm sure in the moment as I
haven't played it it's probably gonna
have some frustrations to it I have no
doubt um but it's one thing that I feel
like we haven't seen that big of a space
for an encounter yet because everything
so far has seemed very mostly room based
per se so there's a little more
traveling around so it seemed pretty
cool to me but again I'm sure I could
also see some frustration so I can
understand that as well
mm-hmm what about you know I mean you
pretty much knew everything I had to say
on it I mean that doubt that was pretty
much it I thought it like I said that it
was a a real cool you know encounter I'm
very curious to see once the dust
settles where people kind of rank it you
know I'm saying and what actually we
need to meet more people to be able to
experience it so then we can you know
actually do someone have fun ranking so
we'll see see but that was pretty much
all I had order rate so now I just kinda
want to get into the whole new character
grind things were thinking about and
this kind of may lead over and the likes
and dislikes but what can I save those
mostly towards last so I mean you as a
new characters you've been grinding
through like how do you feel about where
things are at with mod components
enhancement cores infusion as you're
leveling up and playing this game how do
you feel that yes you've you've done it
before so you know what to do right but
I mean if you were gonna tell a new
person like hey this is what you've got
to do how do you how would that
experience be portrayed to somebody else
I think it's still rough and the reason
why I say that is because I'm coming in
with the experience of what to do
correctly right so I'm not making over
not over infusing I'm not you know I'm
I'm daily going to spider I'm getting an
enhancement core every day you know
these are kind of things that I would
say the casual or new destiny player
might not be familiar with right so you
know you got that aspect but as I've
played now one thing I've realized is
that I understand the place of
enhancement course I'm not I think what
their design choice was like hey we've
got to make choices matter we've got to
make this thing you know not as fast to
get up a little bit you know get up and
level you know kind of things so I
understand that but the negative and it
this goes out to that are that little
piece you sent me I believe I forgot
which I I believe it was uh was it
Christopher Barrett olds it uh cut right
here yeah
where people were talking they were
voicing their complaints with
enhancement code I think my number one
from me is I can't look the way I want
to look like I'm forced like I have
cool-looking armor but just because
something else comes in that has more
highlight I'm forced now to wear that
you know I'm saying the same thing can
be applied to weapons if you're not if
you hate a specific weapon type but
that's your highest light you kind of
forced right you kind of you know what
else you're gonna do so it is still some
things that I don't saying floored about
it you know I understand the thought
process so that's the first thing in
India that's the second thing is you're
obviously which they're gonna hopefully
address with this next patch is just you
know it's it's you know you're doing
your dailies and you're doing all these
different activities it's still a slow
creep man it's a slow creep and I'm
concerned that it's because I love the
game I'm gonna do it I'm having so much
fun I'm gonna do it but I also recognize
I am a small percentage of this
community right there are more
I hate these word casuals then there are
of me right so if I'm a casual person
again I'm not trying to make the game
completely easy that's not where I'm
going with this but
what I'm seeing is you have to
incentivize them somewhat to keep
playing because guys again like oh wait
you guys I'll get Forsaken and black
army I'll get to play with you guys and
then it's like no you're not for like
three or four weeks that's gonna be
changing for sure it's like I'm put in
the penalty bin right now that's how I
feel like a hockey term I'm in the bed
and I'm watching you guys play or nice
and I'm like girl and you're over there
like doing your homework first homework
fam I'm sitting there like I can't even
and I'm hearing the stories and people
like Yoda Forge is actually cool when
she gets up level and then the thing
that's killing me inside to be honest
this is a stupid thing no I have bad
that you have access to ADA that's
that's still the XO's name yeah I got
I'm mad that you got access to component
well mine's the component has that I
will say like like this like saving it
for later that I absolutely I do
I think Bungie made a horrible call
there absolutely missed that because
that is a piece of the game's economy
that is used by everyone doesn't matter
if you have the content or not and to be
able to have to finish the Forge to be
able to buy mod components which I've
talked about forever cuz I have 6,000
weapon parts to use on nothing and now I
do but if you didn't get black armory
you literally can't buy those and I'm
just like no that's um that vendor can
be there to introduce the content hey
you can buy weapon course from here hey
what are these bounties about okay I
have to get the content but you can at
least buy them there you should all be
able to do that yeah and what's killing
me is during this period Banshee has
sold super mods which I desperately need
right mmm III don't have any way of
getting those like I mean I could do the
hustle that screen puts me onto which is
you know you try to take blues from
collections and break down 20 of them a
day and hopefully get to you know I'm
saying to get to the 10 that's required
to get the thing but it's like damage
this new content there and I can't even
utilize that like - sorry I just want to
do something new that's all I want I
wanna I want to be able to
as the you know less than five probably
600 person you know have some semblance
of the new content and maybe they just
need like a a lower light Forge for you
know the beginners like you know this is
your little playpen you go over here you
know say and then you guys have the big
leagues over there but at least the you
know we're touching new content I just
don't like the fact that I'm literally
doing what I've been doing and forsaking
this entire time and I'm just like again
I'm in the penalty box man I'm just
waiting for my time so I can join the
skate on ice with the big dog you are
not wrong because that was the big thing
with the release and they they lowered
it down five levels because that is
meant to be in-game they don't want it
to be easy but you have people who don't
get to try it they don't want to go
grind their old stuff if you're at least
gonna add something new give them a
piece of this I mean they take a
nightfall strike and you do a nightfall
and if you finish it even with zero
points it takes you an hour it doesn't
matter you will get a drop if you go
okay I'm higher level I can crank up the
modifiers I can crank up the handicap
make this thing a challenge then you
have traumatic saying it to then you
actually get a full like then you're
gonna get them you know then that thing
is gonna give you that boost over 600
power and that should be other you know
say it first when you're leveling up I'm
a dramatic set it to your 1 to 2 to 3
there should be like hard there should
be like normal hard and then say like a
legendary difficulty of these things and
be like recommended first 500 you're
only gonna get legendary drops they're
not really gonna help people get a feel
for the mechanics then there might be
one it like you know 550 you might add
like one like one that you have to kill
there's not as many and be like hey the
powerful one you got a little less you
got less time you got to get more
batteries the anything that's as you go
that's rude and then when you say
recommend a power level don't give me
610 and make the final guy six thirty
she recommended 16 to 6:30 give me the
ring so I know what that high end is
like okay there's gonna be a struggle
and also late when you go to matchmaking
yeah
don't let five 80s try and match make
into like a 6:30 activity
like his pee that's what people are
saying is by the way this is a very
prime example mm-hmm they put
matchmaking on this type of activity so
everybody could finally shut up about
wanting raid matchmaking because these
mechanics are not that hard and
blueberries will struggle till they're
blue in the face
so trying to have people do a raid with
matchmaking maybe not talking it's not
gonna happen so like matchmaking on a
raid unless you unless you've dumbed
down the mechanics a lot like and you
have like a little problem and be like
hey this is like a sparrow racing
section like or you have to drag your
Sparrow make it to the end two out of
the six of you have to make it there
like you would have to go like clear on
explain it and then when they come in
then if you were like hey go look out
you know and even if Bungie doesn't ever
want to put like true matchmaking in
that can't be like hey their websites
check the forums there are places to
look to find other people to play with
if you want to run full mechanics for
powerful gear they either have to go
that far and like make people work
together or yeah you're not gonna get
matchmaking so it has to be dumbed down
very low or but giving people options to
experience the content is what they all
want
so yeah that low medium hard difficulty
you know get some blues get some
legendaries get some powerful engrams
when you level up and level that's what
they've got to do yeah no I agree I
agree they have to do that I guess it's
it's just it's a tweak it's a balance
and someone else says something um
recent I want to shout him out um say no
to rage he's you yet um he's got a good
uh video up right now saying hi like the
leveling is it's busted and stuff like
that and a point he made that I thought
actually was a decent idea is even with
the current grind for you know less than
forget less than 600 just in general
even you guys like when you're going
through your your daily powerful Engram
rewards that kind of stuff powerful gear
rewards like what sucks is you know
obviously we know the way the system is
set up it's rng based right it's you
know sometimes you know it's your boots
holding you back right well energy
holding you back so you get it and it's
just like damn another gun so one thing
he mentioned that thing is actually
idea is you know whether it be on
rotators right let's just say the reset
happens you know one set of powerful
gears is giving you armor so you know if
you're missing you know an armored piece
you know I'm saying at least if I do
this activity if I play crucible five
times you know it's gonna give me
powerful armor right and then other one
may say powerful weapon you know I'm
saying kind of deal again not giving you
the specific one that you need to just
make it blow through fast but at least
you can focus on actually what you need
because a lot of times that's what's
been happened to me right I'm like damn
like you know I've been getting weapons
weapons weapons I'm like man I need
armor like that's all I need I can't
even you know get that so I know there
was one thing I thought it was like a
decent suggestion a couple of people you
know I've been kind of commenting on
that you know and as far as the
enhancement cause I'm in the middle I'm
gonna be on surgery I'm torn I I
understand the place for them my only
negative with it is I just don't like it
restricts me from looking cool I want to
look cool that's that's a big part of
Lord God meaning we got to be fly out
here my warlock gotta shine so I don't
like having to put on nasty things just
because the light is higher so which
brings us back to transmog we're getting
to that point now got to happen it's got
there's a way you could I mean I know
the program is not easy I know they're
managing inventory and space and servers
and all those different things but when
you're looking at inventory you're
looking okay so you have your equipment
slot so yea hashtag destiny training
logs like there's gotta be a point where
you know if there's a way for you to the
amount of time it takes you to break
down in exotic you got to hold the
button for a little while say yeah I've
got a hold you know on this thing I've
got a hold right trigger for five
seconds and then this is gonna be you
know this is gonna be your locked
appearance and you have a slot for that
and it just says this is what it's gonna
lock into and you take that like that
you know skin and you attach that to
your guardian
there's that's and stuff for the other
side but you have to I mean that way you
could still like you know take the
inventory where it is but they you do
that and you'd lock it in as your this
is my look
that's the stuff could move around but
this you lock in your look and that's
just like that your character until you
choose to change it and that could take
and you could take some time to update
the servers and things like that because
I mean they still have to do that if you
switch stuff over it takes time for it
to load so after you know ping the
server pull it back and actually get it
to load onto your character and do the
same thing and honestly for loading it's
like then once you load in you don't
always have like the armor switching
around you change the stats but you
don't have to render that character
again and again not a programmer I could
be saying all this and it's completely
false but that would be one of those
things that would be like they need that
point because as you said like infusions
should not honestly cost enhancement
course because that is not the title of
the thing you're not enhancing it I'm
literally bringing it up to my level I
use it so I mean that's one of those
pieces where if I get a new piece of
gear and it's like 620 but it's trash
okay well let me throw that into
something just because I did get a new
drop but I like the rolls on another
piece no you really do that if I'm at a
horse or I'm new and that's the big
thing is about leveling up new
characters it's like something's like
all cool I got the thunder Lord as a
random drop I'm loving this thing and I
have you know I got a head with like
machine gun reserves and I'm really
loving this I got more space ok well now
this thing's five levels higher do I not
equip this thing so I can do higher
level stuff but I come I have Bo
reserves and primary ammo finder and
it's like garbage but I don't have any
coins yet because I'm like leveling up
and I have an end that and it's not
obvious to you see the cores but you're
like where do I get them I don't quite
know it's not the most obvious thing but
also like because enhancement cores are
such a scarce resource generally and
they're they're becoming more apparent I
mean you can't do it but it's not like
I'm going to spend the time to go hell
or high water into a full master work
set of armor right because I'm still
leveling stuff up no common different
roles are coming so like if I'm really
gonna enhance I can't do enhance and
infuse yeah
exactly grind takes long enough just to
get to 650 now X I'm never gonna touch
that full armor and that's the way and
that's no little solar little void
little damage boost it's like hardly
gonna feel like I'm I can't do it like I
don't have the way to do it mm-hmm
blackjack here yeah only a chair right
now I'm gonna get you talking some talk
so basically he we've been having this
in the ebon she had a good discussion in
reference to the whole mod situation and
in the way it's structured right now
because currently the way structure
right now is only through black armory
can you get my components so he's asking
in addition to people who don't have
black armory granting for the black army
weapons in the EDC and necess through
saboteurs they allow a chance for those
weapons to try out the new mods I mean
that's an option I just want another
source you know and you know Banshee
even himself should be part of this as
well right you know there should be a
source whether with some type of economy
exchange to get mod components you know
like again what's he selling here's the
other problem the problem Lawson doesn't
sell the way the ways to get a way to
get them exactly it's like you know you
defeating the perfect and then the other
thing is the drop rates are so low
mmm that it's insane like I literally
get more enhancement cores then I get
mod components oh absolutely
cuz I use those like sparingly now too
like hey something's at like level 1
it's actually really good range roll on
this thing let me boost it if you see
how it's feeling if I like it so I'll
blow through a few master work cores
there but I never touch mount components
because I'm just like I'm so stingy and
I'm a hoarder and you know that you give
me a hard time but seriously you can't
like I'm afraid to use them or buy that
many mods like if they were dropping at
a reasonable rate as much as I play on
this character I should have a stash of
probably everything and I buy them
sporadically like if I see a super I'll
buy like one or two and I have a decent
amount of them but like I should
probably to a point as much as I play
now where I'm rolling in them a bit more
and then somebody who's on a kind of
mid-range casual newer player should
have access to some not at all and what
they should have access to start seeing
some so they feel comfortable to be like
hey let me try this mod on this piece of
armour so I can you know at least see
how this feels right yep
I mean that's just there's yeah over all
wore black check overall ban she needs a
buff yes yes freakin luli you can give
you bounties for new mods that would be
amazing
it's perfect knees I mean he used to
have Balinese he used to have the arms
they and stuff like that be like hey go
get I don't know 500 kills go get even
like a weekly banner go get like 500
heavy weapon kills in you know PvE or
like against enemies not in crucible and
maybe it'll give you like 10 10 mod
components like that's a grind but I
mean it's also like that's gonna get you
a couple Mountain bonus so it's like and
you're gonna kill normal crap throughout
the week and with fun and so like throw
a few of those out there one there'll be
a daily and a weekly so you can have
some stuff to look at treat it like the
planetary vendor planetary vendor has
three specific brownies gives you those
materials that you need for said planet
have been she'd do the same thing if
they wanted to earn new gameplay have us
have us go out in the world do crucible
strikes or whatever activities and like
you said it'll give you like a +5 mod
for finishing them you know so that this
way it just sucks when he comes around
and he has that much you need and it's
like man I got two mods right now I can
literally do nothing
there's no way to farm I'm just screwed
until RNG decides to bless me or I do
the exploit which still takes forever
which is grabbing blues out of
collections and breaking them down
that's not I feel the way I should be
playing destiny to earn my opponents ya
know or blood check he's like solution a
banshee waiting for the response there
but yeah all those pieces are things
where and this is the thing and shout
out to polit SEO is getting some nice
insights in there literally
usually putting in words better than I
could put it in words but all the stuff
that we're generally thinking as well as
like mod components and casually we
worry about casualisation but he said
it's like it's not the casualization per
se because like they've steered away but
it's the access to things and giving
incentive to keep going yes and it's a
balance of and I'm probably even saying
like something here's an article up
wrong but he was just saying it's like
it's not a worry of casualisation it's
like no the game has a grind that's
gonna be there but it's giving you
incentive and access and options and we
have a lot of things to do but it's kind
of the point of why like this is kind of
gonna step on one of my likes and
dislikes but why the hell are strikes in
there yeah what purpose do they serve at
all yeah these are good arguments these
are very very very good arguments
I mean if strikes are go ahead no no no
no please convey I want you to go for
this one continue you're fine go tit
strikes are so misused and underutilized
and also people of God please change the
challenge of the week where you have to
merit matchup on that thing oh wait I
hate that that deadlight element you
have to match the light element of
someone to your party and some people
are just dumb they're working on
bounties they're just not paying
attention to what the singes they're
using just like void tether like void
cinch on a solar burn and then they're
like punching everything on a Grenadier
week and they're like oh ma what do you
believe like they don't even know it's
not like it's blastin on the screen or
they just don't quite see it it's not
just saying hey you click on strikes and
before you do it say solar singes this
week and this is like this is like so
hey you know grenades are gonna do more
damage and solar damage is gonna be
amplified so you know you might consider
switching to that it's it's subtle and a
lot of people just don't notice and yell
like hey I'm gonna do my three strikes
and get my piece of powerful you know
cuz I'm a solo player and they don't
have a clue what's going on whatever and
why it's not completing yeah that or
they're like two blueberries randomly be
on the same thing and they're both on
void and it's a solar since week and I
look down and I see
didn't do it now I've said that's at my
weekly reset videos part of that earnest
is on us to be like okay when I get
about two thirds into the strike I'm
gonna stop for a second I'm gonna look
at what they're running right and then
I'm gonna switch over by the end of the
strike at least I'm gonna match him so I
mean there are ways to help with that
but it shouldn't have to be like I
literally have to check what someone
else's are gonna be like you know just
match it for the week be like okay so
you know it'd be like hey run three
strikes as a solar run oh you had a run
it and that's gonna be your way to
actually have everybody get that
you know that's stuff done scream thank
you for joining us a little late but
always good times great but those are
those ways it's like that will give a
guy BOTS a regular van Groot sorry I
don't care enough to change at nightfall
is a different story
yeah but it's like if you don't change
it you don't match a random person you
aren't making progress on your powerful
gear so then you're literally shooting
yourself in the foot too so I mean they
should just change the way that
challenge is written because it's just
not helping anybody agree but I mean
also like my bigger thing sorry huge
strike rant right now I let's go get it
like where do strikes fit in in the
gameplay like because you'll go through
doing missions and story and I mean
you'll see them as a challenge to do but
I was like where are they on your
progression they don't they don't help
you they don't give you a stepping
they're not a stepping stone in between
anything for a new player they're just
this one challenge you have to do for
powerful gear and then when you're done
you're done that's it but if you're
leveling up and the soft cap hasn't
moved especially that needs to yeah by
the way for leveling people up that soft
cap has got to go got to go up god I
mean make it 550 who gives a crap if you
get up to 550 like if you're new and
you're trying to give people incentive
to get to this new stuff 550 is not
gonna break anything but here is where
you have to use something like strikes
yes or missions
maybe story missions are like hey okay
go do a couple story missions because
you know you grinded stuff out and you
may not have experienced the old story
missions and we have new players new
story missions that might get you
Legendary's that drop up to 560 so this
is above the soft cap of
lose em strikes could take you from 560
to 575 yeah and like weather however you
balance that stuff strikes need a
purpose because you go you know story
campaign and then it's just you know
grind out your challenges but what if
I'm story campaign and I'm like five
twenty what if I go grind strikes and
every time I every single strike mmm I'm
saying like a chance and one in five
that something drops that's gonna tell
you every single strike is gonna help
you level up right it took and you'll
get you're gonna get you're powerful
you're gonna do stuff other places but
those like those are a thing and
multiple things need this kind of
evaluation leads me to bring back up the
d1 classic strike playlist where they
had the scoring system and then you kept
running it and after every three to four
strikes I believe there would be a
chance for reward and then you can make
that you can depreciate it they worried
about people just choosing it you can
depreciate it after every three right so
that you know you're still getting
something but you're not always getting
the top top top all the time you know
it's just they've got they they have to
figure out something to do and I agree
strikes is a great idea like they really
need to do something to in to
incentivize it and divide because like
you said once it comes around a tweak
and you do it you know those three
strikes and you do you know the what you
call it the UM light level thing I mean
like um same like you know director
challenge or whatever yeah done you're
not touching shanks no more so find it
enough that you're high enough level
yeah that's probably all you're gonna do
but I mean if you're like you when
you've been leveling up you get to a
point where like I just wish I had
something I could grind or it would help
me out cuz I've done a lot of my
powerful houses like the you know rank
resets whether it's gambit or Valor
those take some time but if I just like
hey I know if I win and strikes at least
help me move from 540 to 560 and I could
make some progress in there so not
feeling like I'm like oh crap I feel
like I'm done for the week and I can't
like most other games RPGs and things
like that if there's I mean the week
doesn't just stop
yeah exactly if you're at the pinnacle
of like 650 you're like yeah you're up
there there's only so many things that
are gonna start giving you like you know
really making some changes but there's
like you you if you are trying to get to
that level you shouldn't hit just that
final wall of the week and you're like
well I guess I'll play another game
until Tuesday and that's what start
losing these people or new order they're
like okay I made it through the story
the campaign is done okay
Beck's is 650 okay a lot of stuff and
I'm like 525 but I don't have a lot of
things that are like blinking on my
director to tell me there's other things
to do
yep so it's it's one of those pieces and
it's like yeah just that that smoothing
of the transition giving people who were
underleveled
reasons to keep going has got to be
there because as they keep doing this
the next one seven hunt
the next one is 700 same things gonna
happen all over again
mm-hmm and soft cap cannot stay at 500
it just gets longer and longer no I
agree yeah I mean your fire rant mostly
over now sorry I don't go on for a while
your fire I love it it's all it's all
truth man all truth I'm I'm complete
agreement with that but yeah so there's
just a lot of things that need adjusting
to this point because you're they don't
want to capsulize it and I understand
that d1 was exotic drops were really
high you got me how do I feel
let me go ahead and take my headset off
for a second so I can let my ear steam
get out of there's a rate we don't get a
lot of those that's good no but it's
just one of those pieces to we're giving
late
the like throwing the you know exotics
at us and like a lot of things from year
one have changed in into year two we've
got some good progressions and feels and
all those things that are like getting
better to a point but it's if you want
to be like hey this game's free hey I
haven't hey I've got a collection you
know you're gonna sell the Destiny
collection for cheap or it's on sale for
20 bucks and be like hey you know you
can get up to 650 you
Daniel pass if you want but yeah you can
reach max level the grinds decent I mean
if I go out there and made a video of
like hey how to level up okay so you go
through you do your full campaign for
four second you do the dreaming city and
then you do these challenges but when
you're done with the challenges you
gotta wait until Tuesday that's the
horrible sentence to say like that's
gonna be like what yeah so if you go
through it I mean how did you feel when
you I mean you probably didn't have cuz
I mean you're not just a no life or
gamer but I mean but like you know life
did where do you think when you were
grinding that like first week you got to
the dreaming city and then you were
working on your challenges where do you
think you could have hit maybe no lifing
you know as a new PC er how I didn't get
in that first week yeah I think without
restriction I could have got to like
that first week I could have got to like
five five eighty you know I'm saying
like easy go say again if there's no
restriction and we have those things in
place it's like we say oh I'm saying as
it is now without all this stuff oh yeah
that's what I'm saying where do you
think you would get as of this current
state before they do like the Perryman
grams and other powerful x' and you have
to soft cap is still where it is where
do you think you would have got to in
say three weeks ago destiny without any
of these changes like finish the
campaign got to dreaming city okay so
I've got these you know these are all
the weeklies you did everything where do
you think you're gonna capped just
curious mmm man low like there's no
doubt mama I'm just trying to put a
number on it but hey it's almost time
for normal so it's like you do that and
you're like I had so much stuff and I'm
like I am not there but what if you know
life did and you were like hey I hit
like 536 random number whatever and
you're like there's nothing else for me
to do I don't know where to go find
stuff I can't reach black armory so
those are a couple things I can't do I'm
not high enough for the raid I'm not
high enough for shattered throne I've
hit all my challenges and I have this
stopping point and that's one of my
biggest issues with the that you know
getting to the end that parse that stop
is
issue I know it's a hard stop I agree
disruptive and they need something to
continue in that's way like you said
that strikes
I believe I forgot which destiny it was
but a d1 there was an expansion that had
you strikes correctly and it was like it
was like that middle ground you know
saying and you can still you know
utilize it and you know and get get
rewards from it to help you towards that
grind without that hard stop of oh I got
a way to reach reset to all the planets
light back up and then have new sources
of you know getting powerful gear yeah
so I mean that's one of those things
that I think will hopefully get
addressed in time maybe be a d3 thing
but just that and as weak as this annual
pass keeps going to make that annual
prep pass be more appealing that ramped
up needs to be faster and faster as that
higher power cap gets farther and
farther away from where you finish that
d1 campaign because where the D learners
are due to forsaken campaign when you
finish that you're roughly 500 and if
you're seeing like 700 come this spring
as being a place to reach to and you're
like it's only coming from powerful zand
primes and but I mean primes will drop
but I mean they're gonna be more often
in bigger boost but it's like they got
to make that adjustment but I mean the
soft cap in there those all those pieces
but it's like if you're not using
content people are like well I mean
these strikes are here but I hate
playing them because I don't get
anything for him give him a reason
that's all yeah first giant ramp mostly
to the side no point always I mean we
covered the kind of kind of I'm pretty
sure I beat the hell out of the new
players Ryan you know we got it's good
to hear from you as well on that one cuz
you're literally going through it right
now because yelling almost ready for
shatter thrown coming up this week
grisly those pieces like when you get to
new like shattered throne I know it's
like a thing and I know there's probably
a lower piece maybe where it will always
be there but there's got to be a point
in expansions where shattered throne is
kind of like always an option
yeah like it should be like how you're
like
becoming something and you know it
should be selectable once at us they got
to figure out a happy medium with that
mm-hmm yeah I mean what or if you've
beat it before you know maybe you can at
least go run it or sorry
just do something more frequent I know
the three weaker but three weeks is a
long time and that's like one of the
really awesome things in there but and
then one other piece please please
please for the forages let me select him
from the director you have Matt hiking
I'm gonna go into that screen when I
walk up to it don't make me walk up to
it in person let me just start it from
the director so I can just be like hey
I'm gonna play in it let me queue up for
the forge mm-hmm so all right all that
stuff out of the way so we gonna go
three things we like three things you
decide you want to go dislikes their
likes first or kind of all unity like
one and one and switch yeah don't want
to switch so go in negative or positive
first let's keep it positive we've been
we've been in a rant fest yeah that's
right I try to be constructive with it's
good radar you know I'm teasing you um
let me see so the first thing I would
say for me favorite you know I gotta say
I gotta say the new supers you know I'm
saying like the new supers that's on one
of my list you know definitely loved how
they reimagine certain classes and um
you know how powerful they feel that
definitely gives me a sense I'm
definitely feel I have more tools in the
box so to speak you know for different
situations so that's one of my what
about you ah so I mean mine for just
things about destiny is literally just
the way I mean and it's a basic piece of
the game but it's just the way you
gunplay feels guns have ages seats they
have a distinct feel they have a
distinct sound they have a distinct
recoil pattern each gun has certain
purposes exotics are really starting to
feel exotics they're crazy out of the
box stuff just the actual whole gunplay
I mean it is Bungie they nail that stuff
absolutely nail the gun play in the game
and this is no exception so for me it's
one of those things when you look at
other games that are coming you've got
things like division you've got things
like anthem they're gonna have different
things but that first-person gunplay is
I don't want to say second to none but
it is oh yeah
coming back yeah yeah you pick a bugger
and you fire it and I'm like the first
time I fired
what's the SCAF lock in d2 that one had
that kind of it felt a little more you
know a military ocean it it had that
feel but then you pick up a novel on or
iphone this thing it's totally different
the recoil feels a little different you
see the little energy bullet you got it
like all of those pieces and even
grenade launchers are amazingly in a
good spot right now like all of those
and you bring in something like bows and
it still feels pretty good like the aim
assist is in a right spot not too much
but it feel like you're not punished for
not being perfect like just the gunplay
for me has always been an amazing thing
that keeps me playing this game because
I just love how it feels so that's one
of mine hands down for all of absolutely
absolutely all right now give me not
gonna be a big change when you give me a
dislike what do we what do we got all
right
um I'm gonna go with still not enough
powerful rewards for crucible only
players and my thing is if I want to
live in the crucible right I the Week
starts and yeah [ __ ] you have that
player one match you get a powerful drop
play the five you'll get a powerful drop
once that's done that's it it'll be
unless you know during the week the
reset happens and you get another day
with crucible pops back up you know I'm
saying before the reset so it's just
like I feel is still a disparity between
PvE and PvP because there's tons of PvE
sources right turn and again this goes
back to one of my old requests of you
know the true meaning of knowing you
know more about it as sexist have cuz
don't get me wrong
glory is cool but I'm not get you you
going towards the pinnacle weapon you're
not really doing that to level right
so that's where I mean I am banner yes
but I am banner also you know it's not
as frequent it's you know it's a once a
month thing you catch it no doubt it's a
great week kind of thing so I just feel
that they're probably like one will say
activity away but they did still I still
feel crucible as a whole needs to have
another source of powerful what make it
and make it difficult I have no problem
you know ascended challenging crucible
yeah yeah I've got no problem with that
you know zan I've got no problem with
making something very difficult but if
you accomplish it hey you know I'm
saying and again that's the kind of
things that true meaning of what I did
it made you do certain things so what
would that be to you what would you what
would be your addition is this like a
This Means War bounty or do you get away
from a bounty and go for well how do you
because I mean destiny still as a looter
shooter and it's stuff looking about you
wait to it so what is your how do you
add something in what's your so like you
have that it was like but for me I was
like I'm gonna try and do this too and
hear myself over but what is your like I
mean you can have a have an opinion
about something but what I was solution
to - yeah solution I mean listen at the
end the day you bring true meaning of
war back right you get that going and
then obviously the elephant in the room
which needs to happen I feel mm-hmm by
Joker's wild because we know joke as
well does not have a rate right
hello trials hello trials yeah let's
let's bring it back let's let's
reimagine it and and again have those
attachments to it have have the powerful
Engram attachment to have you know that
incentive bring the bones back bring
those things those are the things I used
to do because not only you know did it
kind of gives you even though it was non
adept weapons you know you still had the
adept stuff and the the lighthouse stuff
that was unattainable for the hardcore
but you still had your dailies you know
you still had you know your fire bound
it was
about just activity a lot of them just
was like if you really looked at how the
trials bounties were they were really
just gained towards you know play a
couple of these matches win these couple
of matches it was about engagement it's
literally what it was about so they have
to either do that if trials is not ready
that needs to happen in competitive but
their trials is ready they need to bring
that and add that to that because that's
the high end crucible content yep I mean
I can definitely agree with that for
sure and I'm not even a crucible player
so yeah says who always leaves the
boards I really don't I really really
don't
one of those things I was thinking about
to because somebody on my channel is
left to comment recently and I've had
people ask before it's like I'm not an
amazing crucible player I hold and it's
a kill death assist ratio so I mean it's
definitely higher than one but it's not
like two or three or four it's like 1.4
1.5 Lake somewhere in that I'm probably
about a 1.0 KD but I don't feel like I'm
just getting worked I feel like
sometimes I hold my own sometimes I get
worked there's like I'm kind of walking
the middle ground you know I'm okay at
destiny I know there's people that'll
just mop the floor with me but there's
sometimes in games or I'm like okay I'm
having a good game like I'm in the zone
like and they both happen and just to do
basic tips that like even for me but
somebody's like I step into PvP and I
just get worked mm-hmm what are basic
ways to help with that it's like okay so
shotguns are a popular thing if you feel
like you don't have a comfort doing that
you're not running around corn don't run
around corners pay attention to your
radar or you know play more kind of
range thing use a pulse rifle because
they're in a pretty good spot right now
little stuff like that I was like I'm
honestly thinking about doing just like
PD big pvp pvp basics I'd be good if I
can talk so from an amateur like and
that's and it's like I'm not gonna claim
to be an elitist like you want to go
watch like the fallouts the camis the
lucky and lucky and butt-wipes like
those guys are they're epic
they would kill me every time miss 5,000
watts would snipe me from across the map
with one hand but tied behind her back
like in an
her just like skill-based ranking and
I'm like I'm okay like if I go against
like newbies yeah I'll probably beat
them so it's like are there things that
I could say to help maybe so I was like
when you say crucible but that's a piece
of the game that some people just don't
like because they don't have that space
to get into it and just kind of feel
like they're not just getting destroyed
no I get that but those people also have
to understand like people need other
sources you know saying no no that's why
I was like for you having that like lion
and it's huge but it like that would be
a way to like those pieces some type of
like the skills and that's why I like
getting the glory number actually
attached to who you're matching up with
hopefully as long as like matchmaking is
decent it really starts to set those
skill rankings apart which gives these
people incentive to try some of that
stuff and not feel like oh I'll never do
trials like okay maybe you have like a
week where you do get those five those
were perfect those bounties cuz I never
like I went to the lighthouse once and I
got totally back back there like believe
me the guys I paid how was literally I
was on their team and watching it on
much less the people on the other side
that were like okay they just lost
they're not entirely sure what happened
like it was watching and just in awe
what these two were doing and they just
play together and they were like I said
they were just cool people and help me
out nice but man like the way like the
average group would do it those bounties
you're talking about like hit the floor
or hit the six wins and you get your
armor your get you don't get a full
adaptive version but you get something
that's this that's that piece that pvp
is missing and I think you just
absolutely nailed it because that's a a
piece of the game that people can like
work on and try and improve and there's
that incentive out there with the
bounties and the drops and other stuff
that's actually worth getting I don't
know well great completely agreed all
right well I got a favorite right yeah
hours on favorite I believe it's you
crucible yeah so it's you know you would
did I do it dislike well we both kind of
ran it on that but got it right so I
know I've done one and what I've been
wonderful what yeah what I think I think
I do need a dislike at this point so yes
mine for me is gonna be of an adjustment
that I want to see is
I want to see the game and it's the
rumors we hear and it's where I want to
see this game progress to and honestly
it's like I want to see some numbers in
the game I know there's a vague
statement okay so if I get the new
rampage mod what does that actually do
does it lower it by 10%
putting number on that I suspect yes
like how long does my super take your
charts currently your super takes like
like five minutes to charge as opposed
to timing it okay what does the super
mod do it loader is up by ten percent
well 10 percent 10 percent 10 percent
that's like you know 28 percent that
you'd get a difference on if you put
three on then you can actually say hey
my supers down to that they had some of
that stuff like the literal time chunks
that you would like get to in d1 and
they took that stuff away so those are
things that are gonna help I mean there
are things when you're like hey what
does this mod do and some people have to
go do like data testing and sit around
for five minutes okay how long does this
take to charge ok put one mod component
on reuse it go sit in the hallway
somewhere and be like okay how long does
this take to charge if you just put the
mod kamon on your be like hey that that
one goes it's one of those things that
it'd just be nice to see the numbers
in-game like when they say hey this is
gonna be and you see people do all this
data mining and testing and stuff like
that if I did a masterwork and said hey
you do this you're gonna get another
five percent people don't always go read
the Bungie blog to know that you know
that's how master working armor works
that you get hey every thing is like 1%
put more put more information in the
game so people who don't watch youtube
videos don't read the Bungie blocks you
get the information they need from the
game interface itself like this the UI
has space or if you just mouse over
things then you need more tooltips but
also like I mean when you talk about
numbers the basics of like a little bit
of tutorial like ok so you finished your
first batch of gambit yeah that was kind
of fun right well these are the main
things you need to focus on the ads are
gonna drop these you know if you're you
know if you lost the first round or say
they spawned theirs first you're gonna
have these heavy weight or the what are
the high-value targets come out these
are gonna drop more of more mods so try
and focus on them or more motes so you
can get back up
when these when the Prime Evils funds
there's these things called envoys when
you kill both of those it's going to
help you get more damage towards the but
like they don't explain any of that
stuff and they just expect people to
figure it out and it's not meant to be a
Dark Souls game and honestly if you are
like if you want to click through it
cool if somebody really has the time to
learn or like wants to be like hey
gambit tutorial and just throw some of
that stuff in there or just a couple as
they said like pictures the point and
show what you're doing some of those
things would help a lot of newer players
just to understand some basics at times
as opposed to when we shout out to
follow blaze when he's doing his game
but Academy hey hey I was like those are
good things but it's like it's not in
there cuz there's no specific place to
see anything like you know when you kill
both envoys that's one of those things
when the prime evil is out longer and
longer you know every 30 seconds you get
another modifier so like timing these
things a lot just like little pieces and
they can be like a little PowerPoint
presentation for the people in different
activities be like hey would you like to
see a quick tutorial about gambit skip
it or look at it you get the option you
don't have to but if you're new and
you're like hey I've never done this
before what the hell's happening in this
game you get a feel so my thing is just
more numbers and more information in the
game so you have access to what's
actually happening in front of your face
absolutely they have to they have to be
more transparent shout dis sinister he's
like he wants intellect back change that
I want so back to be favorite number two
for you favorite number two catalysts I
am addicted to catalysts when that thing
drops is just a whole new minigame that
opened up for me
hey I just love a man I just love
unlocking more potential out of exotics
you know I remember when I finally had
got the huckleberry one that was cool
you know I'm saying so and mods for the
most part they've been okay you know say
they broke every messing with target
adjuster you know kind of bars there's
some buzz but there's some mods you know
that I like are you my - bag my major
spec you know boss spec on like a rocket
launcher my shinobi that kind of thing I
like that extra layer of functionality
on top of
ding weapons so catalyst number we are
definitely in there for me love windows
drop so that's alike for me which yes I
mean for me is just the fact that we
actually have roll like the rolls are
back and I think those are in a good
spots with a giant asterisks on the side
I love random rolls on guns and things
and having options and stuff to grind
for and having like different builds
that's what I wanted for ever with
Armour is that you can build like hey
I'm gonna run on your Lord I close and
pulse rifle and I'm gonna go pulse rifle
loader machine gun reserves scavenger I
got some heavy ammo drop in and then
I've got recuperation when I'm picking
up orbs and I got this bill okay cool
I'm gonna survive I'm gonna go
thunderlord
on the whole other side if I want to go
like you know sniper like no sniper
flinch sky per reserve I'm gonna go here
a PvP build because I want to just snipe
as best as possible
that's something to like those are there
but the giant caveat on this randomness
is we've they need some more variety in
the perks and they need the perks to
actually make sense with some of the
guns that they're on not ever put a
hipfire grip on a sniper you have some
more random roles in there that give you
options but not stupid options are you
asking for smart RNG is that what you
asking I'm just asking for ones that
like if I'm gonna have late
do I need range on a sniper rifle nope
that shouldn't be an aqueous or some
that yes but there also should be a
little more like I mean they have quite
a few perks and I know it's like
introducing perks as a thing but it's
like on a sniper maybe it's like maybe
there's a part for Less flinch how do we
not have a perk for Less flinch of a
sniper rifle yeah like on the gun itself
not on your armor but on the gun itself
like maybe you get a ruble with snapshot
sights and low flinch I'm like you want
to talk about something for crucible
there you go
late yeah that's just wood so I love the
roles and the perks on the mods and
that's more of what we lost and wanted
back but they just need to adjust where
certain things can roll and just kind of
give more incentive to other things
no my favorite with a favor would
asterisk what does it gets how about
what I'm up on a dislike for you I kind
of played oh I didn't touch about this
um exotic armor tuning remember yummy
one we had this cool little consumable
it's called glass noodles let's roll
some of these bad boys number one and
then number two one of the cool things
they did with d2 which was hey we're
gonna grab a bunch of these underused
exotics SunShot you know graviton Lance
was damn near reborn remember yes a so
it's like yeah like that was a crazy
swaying crazy sway let you know they
they they attempted a little bit with uh
some armor but there's still really bad
been any Faro throw sense so we need to
get back to that you know let's get dust
off a lot of armor right now that is
sitting there with either bad
functionality things that need to be
reworked and changed you know I'm saying
to make it more appealing like this ton
of stuff tons of warlock stuff I can
talk about that I'm just sitting there
I'm just like I'm never gonna use that
it really has no practical functionality
or it's not doing enough so yeah man
let's get that let's say shout out to
sister
let's rig grass needles great again
because I want that custom ability
customization and I also want exotic
armor now that they've got the rules
I want them the exotics to really feel
buffed up there's stuff that that I mean
that the I'm thinking right now like at
least two is a chest for the UH the
Vesper of radiance there's you know the
star fire protocol this stuff that's
just sitting in the vault like there's
no reason for me to really take this
until something happens but that's what
I get yeah I mean for me I kind of was
on it before but it's honestly just your
progression of activities through the
game for me that means and I was like I
was all over this before it strikes and
stuff but yeah it's just that overall
progression for me of through the game
through leveling up incentive for old
things and just trying to find ways to
use the content that they've got in a
proper way that gives people incentive
to stay around to feel like they're
making coz the worst thing is like not
seeing progress mm-hm and there's points
in time where everybody hits that wall
like if you clear out your director and
you got no challenges you feel like you
are done mmm and it's just that wall and
it just some of those walls that they
have in there and the arbitrary piece of
you know making that crime smooth but
then on the other side for me is these
and we didn't quite touch on this on the
raid so this is kind of an offshoot but
I did want to say it it's like when a
new expansion comes out hmm you get they
got to draw a line in the sand and say
what since the only things that are
gonna carry forward whether they're done
or not are your pinnacle quest type
activities and that's it you get you
don't get to carry forward safe bounties
you don't get in here before keys to
carry anything forward so when you start
and you finish that grind and you're
like eh I'm like six seventeen at the
end of this week and I grinded the hell
of it and that grade is 640 mm-hmm
therefore one that will make them have
to figure out where their raids are
actually gonna fall one what the timings
of those are gonna be maybe it is ten
days later so people don't know life the
thing for three days but they got to
actually start druing some get rid of as
you said find a way to like clear stuff
out and make these next expansions and
these releases be fresh starts because
you just like the hardcore grind set out
and they're still gonna grind it out but
it's just like people were 650 in three
days in the play that's what happens
how in the hell is that ridiculous and I
was like and I was wondering I was like
okay so you could technically on three
characters save seven bounties from iron
banner because they were check okay you
can save six bounties from ascendant
challenges okay that'd be powerful gear
on each I mean you could save it
load of stuff but then when I heard
about raid keys from the new raid the
fact that they have like you know they
could go in and save that and they could
open like six chests or something insane
and they could have saved those up for
like weeks of grinding the crap out of
the raid all like those like that other
end of the progression needs is like to
balance as well so when that new
expansion comes out everybody's kind of
on a fresh page not the no lifing
streamers who saved up 14,000 of
everything get that fix again so it's
like bigger than I did that one Forsaken
came out because it was like completely
revamped in so many ways before Satan
gave them other options with all these
like bounties and stuff that you could
save that you just click on I mean you
get powerful gear so just to see the
progression kind of gets smoothed down
and then a releases be handled it
handled in like kind of a draw the line
in the sand and now everybody progresses
forward equally type way so that's my
dislike of just the overall progression
so yeah no I agree I agree and I think
the last saw that was that I think for
me as far as favorite gun yep yeah final
favorite I like I do like the the idea
of priming grams I do feel that was you
know when they introduced it another way
to kind of the boost you up you know
that falls outside of their just that
limited scope of what the weekly you
know kinda activities lead so you know
it's it's another drop and hopefully now
with this extra scale come Tuesday with
the new patch will actually have more
benefit you know two guys that are you
know still trying to level to get to the
to the coroner DLC so I thought the idea
was cool you know I'm saying cuz again
I've been playing you play crucible you
see one traveler oh okay
you know so I like that idea of of
constantly still being have the a chance
of leveling outside of just a regular
standard the static powerful gear drops
yeah mine is gonna be gambit I smell
gambit when you have that match that
feels good if you get work and you get
solo cute against a team we all know
that doesn't feel good but gambit in
it's like optimal setting so either
random teams or team vers team who are
working
you're talking or you're with randoms
and everybody's kind of like a little
off and lost those ones where you have
that tug of war with like the you know
probably people getting healed on the
side and healed on this side and you
take a second you gather yourself and
you try and go again you get invaded
somebody and like you have that tug of
war that is when that game mode feels
amazing and that's literally what
happened when at first when they did the
gambit stream they have all the exotics
they didn't have the AI clothes they
just had kind of a regular loadout yeah
and watching that like between the two
of those teams they weren't melting the
boss in three seconds with chaos reach
and I closed shotguns and all of those
things when it was just in that normal
state that game mode is so so cool if
they can work on you know it whether
it's the primeval mechanics where you
have the boss phases or things like that
but when it's right that game mode feels
amazing oh absolutely
it's so it's fun it's really fun I
really enjoy it I really do enjoy I have
to give me a idiot it is tension the
invasions it's it's a cool but I knew
the minute remember I played it first
anything what about that you know they
got something they got something you
know it's unique and now it's really
enjoyable so I'm with you on it yeah so
that's definitely one for me that just
like it's kind of like that and then
also I have to add another one because
it's the things I didn't expect with
forsaken to enjoy the most
we knew raids we knew story we knew
strikes we knew guns are gonna be fun it
was gambit and it was shattered thrown
about that thing because as a PvE player
they've never put anything of that
in-game activity in that has a triumph
or a challenge or anything for a
specifically solo player yes they built
it to be a pain in the butt but it is
doable because I actually did finish it
finally just is that that's that end
game PvE I'm by myself and if I can do
this holy hell that was an amazing
moment right so shattered and just the
fact that like you get a three person
like for basically full raid
yeah it was like yeah both of those
unexpected pieces of like I didn't know
until I played him that I was just blown
away so I mean those are my look at my
favorites the unexpected of forsaken
were my huge winner yeah all right final
final change final dis yeah I think
already went over it which is uh you
know the voice narrative voice narrative
stuff you know I just like I said that
that was a little sore spot for me for
uh black army just you know kind of
Sunday driving in the backseat looking
at which I'll do it because is so like
your guardian talking to I gotta I gotta
chime in and add that there's like just
the fact that leg there's no you don't
have the unmanned the ghost is kind of
there they're quiet most of the time
you're listening to other but you don't
feel like you're you just feel like you
as you said you're that passenger and
it's just yep keep going I just had to
say that about the garden you know why
I'm bringing it up and I like I said I
can't go into too much detail but there
is a highly anticipated game that is
coming next year
that will be releasing that will be in
competition to destiny and they're not
having that problem based on what I have
seen and allegedly played early so I'm
just telling my des to be fair you know
they got to get it together
you know they they got to get it
together shouted dizzy to goska stay
quiet
no no that's the house he's stealing
other Lizzie do the damn good Kade no
gotta give that but um no but yeah just
real talk like they they have to they
have to clean narrative and lore up
because the competition is coming and
I'm very curious about how destiny is
going to react when that competition
comes so that is why I will continue to
stress lor lor narrative law whether it
be a cinematix great if it's not
narrative voice do the the the last wish
raid is an example that proves to me
they are capable of doing it
correctly please keep the standard
that's all I'm saying
yeah no I mean I can't agree with that
any more than you already did but it's
like yeah the voice part has been one of
those subtle things that when everybody
freaks out that our our Guardian had
eight words we lost our mind like that
is a problem yes I mean just I know it's
not an easy thing to put in I know
there's other pieces but it's just the
fact that we've like our Guardian
whoever it was was talking to Caden
Ian's saying no don't like you can have
a motion beside behind some of those
voice actors I mean uh Eris morn she's
like have you ever heard her own podcast
show it sounds really cool but like when
she gets into that voice like her
emotions her tone the things you're
saying when she's like no I'm not gonna
lose another one like she gets it like
the way you feel when certain things are
said wait that's a voice actor making
you like take us and like step and feel
something and everything in destiny for
our Guardian tends to feel so empty yep
and like I said literally a shell but a
go shell but I mean you literally this
empty shell of like mmm here I'm looking
at you but I I'm a mute I got none like
I got nothing and like I said they the
competition that could look who is
coming and they are addressing things
like this in I mean big time and big man
I cannot wait until I am free from NDA
that's all I got to say so final dislike
for me oh we've covered so much actually
good bad and otherwise there's actually
tough just cuz we've actually discussed
so much I'm trying to think of something
kind of separate and unique and I've
been thinking about kind of so many
different things
Oh besides somebody just floor in a
Mustang in your background can I not
fight against ammo mmm
heavy all really but I mean heavies a
big one because it's such an important
thing mm-hmm
just sometimes the ammo struggles are
like a thing
why on earth they ever took away heavy
Bix drop bricks dropping from orange the
inconsistency sometimes a win leg you
know it's shotgun and it's like I'll see
you like six eight more bricks on the
ground up like specials in the ground
I'll run around and like and then I
can't get one special Engelberg to save
my life for like the next round of you
know orange or something like that just
the deficiency the invisible juggler the
inconsistency it's like I mean if you're
running around and killing guys I should
I mean I don't need to swim in it but
just look at me and see like hey a drop
make it a little bit of a run but always
have like the option for me out there
that's gonna be that's gonna be a thing
so it's it the ammo some it's like it's
just like little nitpicks like that just
like ammo sometimes the useless perks on
things and just things when they're like
hey it working to give you all these
options and so much is out to random
it's like don't have the world be up in
the air when you don't even know what's
gonna happen because sometimes they've
got to be playing be like oh my god this
was just dumb like you know they have
those face ball moments that's like why
did we do this so yeah just it's just
inconsistent sometimes you sit there you
swim in and other times it's such a
drought and you're like why I agree
yeah and just yeah it's just all that
just a little stuff I mean we've we've
probably set a tone so I don't need to
like pick a full major topic to go over
again cuz I mean there's a lot of things
this game does right and the story
forsaken the raid and all of those
pieces now like so much is great but
it's just like the things that they need
to tweak and uses that competition has
come in like literally February and
March there's two games that are coming
out they're gonna be people are gonna
step away to see how they feel and if
people are like hey I stepped in I tried
and I couldn't get that far we don't
have that much coming with you know
Joker's wild like all those things are
happening around a time it's gonna be an
interesting time again
I mean we're seconds in a great spot but
this is again gonna be another test for
destiny because
they want this life in the game but
unfortunately for me it's kind of the
point of some time it may be time to
step away for a breather even for
somebody like us I'll still play some
but it's like I'm gonna want to try
other stuff too and they just have to
have enough of a awesome swing coming
back whether it's the number or the fall
so no they've got they've done enough
things again well that they can be like
hey by the way
destiny is still here and we're gonna
kick some butt again like they got to
make sure and have that in the pipeline
otherwise they are gonna have a struggle
uphill and I think and I definitely
think um trials needs to be Freddy's
trials is a big one to keep some people
incentive to be like hey I go through in
a play I mean uh that's like another
some games it's like I mean anthems
mentioned out there's just one but it
doesn't have that PvP piece and if
people want that that is another piece
for them that's like it's an important
factor of maybe they go do the anthem
campaign and they level up but they get
to the end and I want to shoot some
other people and that's a way for them
to try and come back so it's like the
the options of other games and what
they're learning continues to be a thing
that destiny has to evolve and they're
trying and they're getting quicker but
they just can't fall behind at this
point yeah absolutely
absolutely and I completely agree it is
it's gonna be interesting man but I
guess I think they got opportunities to
do some things man they got an
opportunity to do things I'm very
curious how they react especially uh
first half of 2019 yeah so I mean they
have a calendar and it's and just
sometimes a little bit of communication
and they really tried to lay it out
there but just yeah like this this step
at the first step of black armor it was
like totally out like they they stepped
off and they rolled down the hill a
little bit now they gotta pick
themselves back up again and I wish for
me my final wish is that whatever like
forsaken feels like you got its full
development time and it's like whatever
if there's a d3 or if there's a destiny
to fill in the word if there's a full
thing again it's got a like think I want
a full game if whenever three happens if
it does or something to that level of
like of complete rework that they don't
for one rework it again cuz destiny one
like you had to make it in a year
because there was the whole story right
that's new to you
like you heard 16 months and just don't
do it for destiny 3 and I'll be happy
because if you just keep learning you're
good
don't forget what you've learned just
stop forgetting what you learned yeah
that's all hey I'm glad you said that
because I'm worried with them that when
they have their mountaintop moments like
a forsaken and I'm not saying black
armories a failure but you know what I'm
saying like they always seem that we
just can't kick to great deal seas of
the row like the last time I think it
happened was like rise of iron and and
and taking Cain right but even then
there was like such a long time between
the total it was a year between those
two besides that like one strike and
kind of can we have two great things
without any controversy between and you
know it's almost like they forget like
you said what they learned and you're
like why like a good and like I said
2019 you cannot afford and I will stress
this to the girls come on you cannot
afford to have any type of missteps
because your player base will not be
loyal
they have already shown then when they
pissed off they will leave we that's the
start of d2 and competition whoa it
ain't gonna be much easier so this this
is the time to tighten up do what the
community wants in for the most part
with any reason you know and do the
right thing because they found a shin is
day I mean it still has the best gunplay
in any game you know I'm saying still
one of my the best cooperative
experience I feel ever I feel raised or
the greatest things in gaming you know
I'm saying so it's just like they've got
the foundation just just expand just do
the right things don't go off the beaten
path too much and give the people what
they want
yep yeah no I mean I think that was uh
we went long of course two and half
hours you guys sticking us with us for
so long yeah they're awesome and also of
course a little crazy likeness but
that's the passion for destiny and
that's one of those things that it has
going for it is the community is there
if you
treat them well so they just keep like
ya keep learning
don't don't hit your head and have
amnesia and try and do something
different be like alright we're going
down this path okay I'm gonna go down
this fork over here what happened all
that stuff yeah well we're gonna
complete they can't have a d2 year one
again again otherwise like Yagami 20
2004 he said the same thing up mm-hmm in
your child he said it can't it can't
afford to have vanilla be me to MoMA if
they have that in 2019 it's over I agree
so I think that's where we're probably
gonna wrap it up guys we're trying to
come up with some stuff to talk about
and of course goes long because yeah we
we got words and opinions and things
like that yeah you guys have been
awesome this morning chats been
definitely bumpin so thank you guys very
much you want to start wrapping this
thing up yeah man you know week find me
at law kognito on twitter man or this
Sunday iron Lords podcast this will be
the last Sunday iron law podcast of 2018
we will regroup in 2019 January 6 but uh
this week get a little special guest
he's good content created by man the
PlayStation brah this guy is hilarious
man fantastic content great ambassador
for gaming so we'll have him in the
realm and of course we'd be talking
about all the latest and greatest topics
in gaming all the latest rumors with the
PS 5 and the xbox - what's Nintendo got
up this leaves we got some great topics
please check us out it is sunday on the
iron law podcast Channel and that will
be at 11:00 a.m. Eastern Standard Time
come check us out and if you don't check
it laughed and uh catches during the
week man go go to the channel check so
we have great content there as well as
combat talk with the king we also have
our stream team we do a lot of our first
looks and impressions of known
up-and-coming games check that out and
of course the best to man podcast
destiny podcast
out there flashpoint soon to be at
Guardian Con so if you guys I've got
income please say what's up to us reach
out meet-and-greet do what you got to do
we are looking forward to actually
meaning a lot of you in the flesh if you
guys happen to go next year so that's
all I got
yeah same here you guys if you're
watching this live obviously you know
how to find me on Twitch on Twitter it's
Yvonne Tucson both just kind of been a
weird time for videos on the channel so
I know you guys have been following but
it's just like trying to figure out
spending the time grinding on stuff
which I might just you know stream and
just hang out with you guys if I'm like
I'm gonna grind through this little
quest line and record it all and hang
out with you guys but then on the other
side it's like you know trying to get
like solos and things it's like where do
I spend my time right now and some of
its more just trying to get me crime
doing multiple characters and helping
people with certain things and trying to
get my friends to play a little bit so
it's been a little all over the place
but as always thank you guys
less than two thousand away from thirty
thousand subs that'd be crazy so go yeah
you guys have all been awesome in chat
you got vagabond dramatic you got me all
you guys Jake if I don't say your name I
am sorry
war blackjack all you can hack is out
today see a bunch of people talking in
chat thank you guys it's been awesome so
if you guys ever want to hit me up I'm
gonna put my battlenet in chat it is
mostly where I play I'm unfortunately
not much on console anymore I mean Izzy
bonta's you'd be Ont is number thirteen
old five on battlenet hit me up send me
a message didn't some people have you
just like add me as a friend I don't
know who they are and have to pair my
friends list down because apparently you
can only have 200 on battlenet which is
weird oh yeah twelve thirteen twelve
thirds Cognito one more at twelve
thirteen yeah so hit us up yeah you guys
have been awesome lately the supports
been great I'm gonna see like I kind of
went back to the site looking for the
like way to get the audio up for you
guys as well so that's that's a work in
progress or working on kind of a logo
for the actual audio thing too so
that'll hopefully kind of coincide
together so still gotten things going
we're not going anywhere this is 43 I
know we started in about January we had
a few weeks off in between but you know
we're coming up on a full years of
podcast all this so it's fin it's been
pretty cool so thank you guys for the
support the kind words the chat the
awesomeness you guys are all amazing and
thank you every day for just hanging out
and playing destiny and having the
passion that we do and
dealing with the ridiculousness lawn-boy
yep
so you guys are awesome we will see you
soon and on my end
have a good one and enjoy your weekend
likewise peace see ya alright I'm off